[Applause]
[Music]
look at that opening makes it
makes it look
like we we do like we know what
we're talking about it's a real show it
really does look like a real
show who did the animation was that who
did that JC did you do that b man jump
in here
B I did that but I used a
template what do that mean uh somebody
like built a photo collage thing and I
just went in and I plugged in all of our
show artwork to it better than I could
have done so I I thanks I had a small
hand in the uh
creative I classy well thank you
um I enjoy watching it makes me feel
good don't go away we weren't done come
back
B uh yes thank you thank you for putting
that together I don't give a if it
is a
template you you cared enough to send
the very best
I good energy you know people
should get excited about the show it
reminds me of the bar because like when
that's playing in the bar everyone's
like not so much here
no not in your basement no not at all I
guess we should start the show proper
kids welcome back to fat man beyond I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Mark bernardon hey
ho um we are uh gathered here
today to get through this thing called
like um to talk geek shop kids
me and Mark we got thoughts feelings and
we're angry are we oh not angry enough
to get them
clicks I I like my YouTube is a
c of you know go woke go broke
why Marvel's failed and we told
you and stuff like that and lot of them
have like high hit
counts we should call this
episode everything wrong with
Marvel yeah or the Marvel's worst
movie ever made and then dot dot dot and
then you know that's the card and then
you know inside the description dot dot
dot is what the internet is saying Kevin
and
Mark have different opinions
you
know bait and switch the thing I accused
of with Masters Universe to
actually do it with this
channel bman get in
here there he is can't we get some like
outrageous art cards every
week thing that you know show me and
Mark stepping on something beloved or
something like that
it's like um have you ever seen on those
like pickup trucks it's like Calvin
looking over his shoulder peeing on
somebody or peeing on something maybe
that's just every week it's you guys
looking over your shoulder peeing on
whatever the thing is that came out that
week there you go people be like they
get you have to change it up you have to
change up the image that's what they all
those angry sites do like there's new
art work for every video and it's always
a series
of like this is the worst with
outrageous eyes on people and
you know they with the artwork for
whatever it is they're mad about and
like that get HS we should start
trading an outrage man I mean basically
you're suggesting JC go undercover like
intern at Fox News for a while and like
learn all their secrets and then come
back and I don't think we even have to
go that far think the secrets are
apparent on front page you my YouTube it
just says man like you hate on
something there are enough people to be
like what because you know what the
formula is it's very
simple um you will like if we just put
up our show art which is like this is
what we talk about maybe you get some
cats who are like oh I'm interested in
those things or I like those guys but if
you on something not only do you
get the all the clicks and
people who are like I hate it
too too but then you get the clicks from
the people who are like what I love that
thing how how dare you and we'll
watch it enough to to register the
clicks so I think all of our artwork
should now be outrage
driven overthe toop you know just
nihilism I think we have to have a chat
about what you're watching that this is
your for you page it's just it's because
I click on videos about like like here
what is it not screen R screen Crush
MH like they never make negative videos
that and what's the other one that I
watched the dude Eric Voss new rock
stars or something like
that they do my favorite
videos about like hey here's what we saw
and here's the breakdown and here's some
Easter eggs it's never like
this in its ass it ruined my child you
know what I'm it's all that the
fact the doesn't being that angry make
you tired because of that Mark just to
answer Mark's question because of that I
think that's how you know videos of
people who don't like things show up in
myig I'm probably you know let's be
honest during Master's Universe I'm sure
I clicked on
one or two
videos my algorithm is like oh
he must like outrage and it's like I'm
I'm not I'm so like I don't like outrage
but if that don't get clicks so I
think we should
rethink everything let's Ultra
mean about everything how
everything sucks and and our childhood's
been ruined and I mean if you
ask the internet that's how I am every
time all the time anyway great halfway
there I just gotta make it I just got to
stop liking things so much I have to do
that we don't have to change a
thing just change the artwork it's
advertising right remember that whole
episode of madman when he's like it's
toasted there you go us get posted
that's all it'd be even better because
they'd watch the entire episode right
waiting for the moment where we are done
building the thing up and we're like but
it sucks
and then we just end the show and they'd
be like oh it must be next week and so
our viewer retention think it's next
week they would immediately be on to us
episode one they'd be like they didn't
they didn't on it at all I think
that card
artwork maybe fing to us and then by the
second show they'd be like oh I get it
you're
lying you edged us for four hours and
you never let us come and now
I'm supposed to come back thank you for
putting it into the parlons of our times
you're right it would be would be edging
them with a card and then not delivering
I I you know I don't I don't know maybe
you flip a few right as they're sitting
there waiting for you to on
something maybe they're just like hey
you know talking about things you like
as opposed to like just carping
on everything you hate maybe there's
something to this I doubt it outrage we
know the format it's that simple why are
we even talking about let's just
implement we have to make people
mad or no we don't have to make people
mad we have to be as mad as people
get based
on you know
movies can you can you wrestle up that
kind of outrage Mark uh I I love the
shortterm
solution a long-term problem you know
what we do we're gonna just fake it
it'll be fine it'll last
there's some producers angle into this
you're like no a podcaster could
you know make a hit by losing a
lot of money or whatever the
it just sounds like it'd be very
tiring for three people who pay their
bills in other
ways I just I can't get that mad
like nothing
nothing things in the real world world
don't make me that you know why would a
why would why would a movie that
like I didn't invest in other than like
my
time um you know I don't know just it's
yeah like I've worked on things that
were shitty and I'm not as angry it as
they are about a thing they did not work
on that probably they saw for
free and are somehow incensed in its by
its existence
I ain't on it I say we need to
adopt that that needs to be the way
forward for fat man beyond in order for
us to survive and thrive in this angry
hate clicky economy we gotta gotta we
got to tell them we gotta carry the
gospel dude go woke go broke or some
like that every maybe that's what
we change the name of the show
to um
yeah there's a lot of videos I
saw I didn't watch them all but I mean I
just saw like I scrolled through because
I was looking for the SC you know
eventually found both Screen Rant and
new rock stores because I love that like
hey did you know this like in this
Screen Rant video uh that's up for the
Marvels he talks about the post credit
scene which spoilers if you haven't seen
the
Marvels um hurry uh but but um
you know I'm sure by now you've heard
about the post-edit scene which in like
in another era would break the
internet break the world people be like
holy they're crossing over with the
X-Men and like
that and now it's just people going like
you
know too little too late whatever the
but in any event the dude is Scream
R dude's always working with a little
dog um he theorized that uh the spoilers
if you haven't seen the Marvels uh at
the end Monica Rambo winds up in X-Men
world but which X-Men World we're not
sure but we see the Beast and Beast is
played by Kelsey gramar again his voice
and he had played him in the movies and
yeah put that spoilers up so you
know everyone's like holy the X-Men
you know but then there was also binary
who was never in any of the movies but
that was Maria Rambo Monica Rambo's mom
which in this universe she's binary
binary is a character that goes back to
like 1982 X-Men you know and then redcon
later on I think they made it a
different origin story than what it had
in 82 but um what the character had in
regardless sh's up in the X-Men Universe
what the new what the screenrant guy
said was that's the C T Universe of
X-Men not like the the X-Men Universe
we're used to from the movies but the
animated a liveaction presentation of
the animated X-Men Universe from the old
cartoon that they are now about to
sequelize on Disney plus like X-Men 97
or whatever the they're call and it
was a pretty so Rock Solid
Theory man like I was that guy sold me
he sold me like remember loose change
that movie where they're like
911 was a conspiracy and because
it had that creepy score you're like I
believe every
word that's until you know you turn it
off and then you're like wait a second
um that that that had the same kind of
effect on me man Screen Rant guys going
like that that's gonna be the cartoon
X-Men I'm sure they would like you to
stop talking now yeah like don't compare
us to loose chain stop stop stop that
video's got a lot of hits on YouTube as
well out that
book start combining all of our content
with
conspiracy um but I like that idea I
like the idea that Beast was the
animated version of Beast and their
argument was like he's in a white coat
he's got the glasses he looks like the
animated the animated the cartoon
version of Beast my question to you
though I mean we're going super deep
super fast yes um that's how I Mark
hey super deep super fast
opposite guy I I don't I'm I'm
all like I don't know why I'm
pitching my goods to you and the
audience but I'm not a straight to IT
guy I'm a I'm a a lot of Fourplay guy
anyway moving
on I don't have the wrong idea that
straight if you were going to do that
with the Animated Universe then why do
you get Kelsey
Grammar because Kelsey Grammar is not
from the Animated Universe he's just
from the movie universe true
but I think they're
gonna what am I talking about I don't
think the screen rank guy
thinks that they're gonna bring from a
couple different eras of X-Men like
we're not gonna get Patrick Stewart
because remember they twisted his head
in in h
Wanda or I mean rather Doctor Strange 2
the Multiverse of Madness or whatever
the um but like we'll get James
mavo
Professor
X so they're going to mix up
the I'm so exhausted by all all of the
all of the all the animated adventures
are gonna be
Canon and his his evidence is kind of
strong because he's like look what they
did what if and all that shit's Canon so
they're like they don't accidentally do
things there he's like this has been
thought out and I'm I mean
nothing has made me more tired as of
late than multiverses and thinking about
multiverses and multiversal storytelling
and is this or isn't this and what are
they going to choose and how's it going
to be like I
just I mean I man I just don't
care I want to care sign of old age Mark
I'm gonna be 52 years old I don't have
it in me to give a fun I'm 53 that means
I should be over this too but
still I just don't have it in me to
track which Earth We're on is this Earth
818 616 214 like I don't have it do you
like I think it's much it's easy to see
now in retrospect but don't you
feel and they couldn't have done it so
this is ridiculous but like
ideally for people who like love the
early Marvel Universe movies or like
them all up until like 10 minutes ago or
whatnot like ending at end game
oh you know I would have broken my heart
because I make all these movies
man I'll watch lesser I'll watch mid
Marvel I don't give a
but I'm sure on some level there's like
man I wish we had either just like
bowed out gracefully for a few
years then came back with like X-Men and
fantas 4 maybe not maybe they're like
look and then we'd all lose jobs like
once the money machine is going you
can't stop but what happens when the
money machine
doesn't cough up money for the first
time like
ever that's what we're going to talk
about tonight we're gonna get get into
it right now and stuff but yeah we'll
get there we got some to take care
of first shall we
do good let me tell you where I know boy
we just Dove right into it and um I
have been through some Mark not me
so much uh as my wife so two weeks ago
we were um moving remember remember the
I put my house up for sale I moved out
of my house that I lived in for like 20
years and should bought a house in the
valley we moved there um and then we
went back East uh over the summer made
the 430 movie um then we came
back and our house went up on the market
I think when we got back like there was
an article in the Wall Street Journal
about all the reporter and
stuff and
um by All rights that's where the story
you know ends we bought a new house we
moved into it we sold our old
house life
goes uh two weeks ago we moved back into
the original
house so I am now back in in the same
house that I've been for decades um I'm
not in the same Library where I always
was uh my in-laws used to live with us
Galen Byron as you know uh and they got
their own place so I took their old room
over and this is going to be my new
office I'm as you can see we're I'm
still in the process of unpacking uh all
the stuff was moved back the moving
people were like you going do this
again four more
months um we were in the process we
moved on Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Thursday night I had to
leave um some people are like why the
did you move back in your house
long story but essentially it's just a
financial thing at the end of the day
made more sense for us and sentimental
like nobody wanted to give up the house
and stuff this is where we raised our
kid but anyway that's not here nor there
because the big part of the story is
coming so I left on a Thursday
night the November 2nd because I was
going back East to SM Castle Cinemas and
um we were doing a show with the Russo
Brothers which we and was
great we'll eventually put it up on on
YouTube and stuff uh but what a great
show uh they came out and chit chatted
and we did their entire career and
stuff um so I left on Thursday night on
red
eyee left this house at 10 o'clock um
went to the airport got on my plane you
know got on the plane like 11:20 or
whatever text my wife say I'm on the
plane didn't hear from her figure she
went to sleep landed in New Jersey at
seven or
eight uh first text I get is from my kid
going like have you landed can you call
me never a good sign no is not she do
text me at what would be 4: or 5 in the
morning her time in Los Angeles she
didn't text that early she's like a late
sleeper so I call her and and she's like
before you know you say anything
everyone's fine and when somebody says
that you know somebody's
up and I was like what happened and she
told me the story of what happened so I
leave here to go to the
airport at 10
o'clock about an hour later Jennifer
locks up the house double bolts the
front door
um you know she got the two German
Shepherds lucky and
birdie uh goes up to
bed you know has her water she puts on
the
nightstand uh we have a bed that's on a
One Step Up platform so in the in the
primary bedroom suite the bed is in what
they call an Al
Cove a recessed area that's just the bed
it's got curtains and stuff and there's
one step to get up to it
this step I've slipped on many times
over the course of two decades living in
that house if you're wearing socks and
it's wood
floor Jennifer years ago at one point
slipped and split her chin on
these same steps so they're one
step man you would think like oh my God
but it's it can get you and it got her
that night she turned off the light and
spun you know turned get into
bed and foot went
out and she went back and mercifully
missed the end table which was like this
far away from hitting her Temple
that would have been it instead she
lands on the stair on her hip now my
wife has very pronounced
tips um I think I could say
this yes um you know they're like
handlebars um I know that
because I've used them as such so she's
she's got these pretty pronounced hips
she landed on her hip what
happened was her ball and socket joint
of her leg smashed through her
hip Fe I don't know what the they
call it
shattered hip she went down
boom so she's in the dark screaming in
agony she said like look I've given
birth this was 5,000 times worse she's
like I never knew this type of pain
existed she said it was
excruciating dogs are like all around
her and but she can't move
and she's like in agony she has her
phone on her mercifully she calls Harley
and she's like I need you to get over
here because I'm about to call the
ambulance and you know you gotta break
into the house because I double bolted
the front door sure enough the ambulance
got there with with the
firr and you know they we have a keyless
entry punch code and but if you've
double bolted the door don't
matter you're not getting in but the
fire Chuck's like hey man we got the
ladder so they put a ladder up to the
Second
Story um where the bedroom windows were
open and and they're about to go in
to minister to Jen who's like screaming
on the floor in the dark and
then the two German Shepherds appear at
the window to be like it's a
German shepherd man to be like who the
is entering the house woo woo wo
woo and the EMTs are like we can't go in
the house if the dogs are there like we
can't take that risk so Harley and
Austin her boyfriend show up and Austin
breaks into the house goes and unbolts
the front door EMTs come in took
six of them to get Jennifer out she was
screaming the whole time Harley
said like
just in agony her leg was attached to
her body but just dead because
it was not functioning and
uh they couldn't take it to Cedars
because it was crowded so they
took it to the Kaiser Permanente on
Sunset and she was in the ER for a long
time and and then on Saturday
that was Thursday night Saturday morning
she had emergency hip
replacement surgery she 52 dude sound
like like in our 70s and it's like oh we
replaced the hip and and she's not
Prince so she hasn't been doing a lot of
dancing and there was no like yeah
exactly like oh the wear and tear I've
put on this I knew I was going to get
hip she you know never in a million
years freak accident and now
sets her back like two months so I have
been
home here with her ever since and
abandoning everything else and just
playing nurse maid is that that you
could say nurse maid right that's not i'
because I've been both nurse and mate
and you know it's um a lot of like
somebody who's in agony like
once she's sitting we're laying down
she's okay but getting to that position
you know out get in the bathroom ouch
all this
so I I like I haven't left this house in
I don't know how long um because
I've just been
like kneed deep
in in in recovery and um what a
what a weird tur of
events um I so yeah if I seem a little
all over the place my apologies however
I did since I'm here and sitting with
Jen all day I get to watch a lot of
I'm trying to spin it you know like
because nobody wants to nobody wants to
bust their hip at age 52 you
know what I'm saying so you know what
that comes along they told me when I had
my heart attack they're like you may
suffer depression because you're
middleaged middle-aged men and with a
heart attack they tend to suffer
depression I never suffered depression
but Jennifer shattering her h
bro like you know she's skirting toward
depression because it's like the
man like am I an old person and
like that so I'm trying to spin this
whole thing as like this is a station
like you know we get to stay
home and watch a bunch of movies
and stuff back in the old
house you know what I'm saying meant to
be baby it ain't just like you know get
me to the toilet you got to keep
a motherfucker's spirits up right
because that will lend toward healing
you don't want her to fall down some
rabbit hole where she's like life
and you know that that could happen when
I am a heart attack I was in and out of
the hospital in
less than 50 hours um you know
and that's a testimony to how
good my doctor was and like
that and I didn't ever really feel like
oh my god I've been felt I
honestly still have never dealt probably
with the psychological emotional Fallout
of coming that close to death I
immediately started doing routines about
it and doing it on talk shows and
like that um but that came from the fact
that I never felt like I'd been felted
like I said I was in and out of the
hospital less than 50 hours Jennifer is
laid up for minimum two months like she
knows something happened to her and
that's what my doctor said to me about
the heart attack the day I left the
hospital he goes how are you feeling I
feel great he goes well that's the
problem I said why he goes because time
was when you had what you had back in
the day we'd have to saw you open crack
your you know rib cage go in
there your play with your heart and
then put you back together and you would
lay there for two months healing from
that alone from the chest crack and you
would know that you went through
something he goes but look you feel
great and you're walking out of the
hospital he's going that's very
deceptive because you could wind up
going right back to the same behaviors
and and I could see you here if I'm
lucky you know a couple years from now
and if I'm unlucky you drop dead
so the choice is yours and so I that was
when I was like I'll go vegan and
um although this week man I feel like
like I since I haven't gone a runion in
a week and I've just been sitting around
eating comfort food with the wife I feel
I feel I gotta get back to
running I gotta back to my Hill yeah I
really do man it makes a difference and
not you know some people are like I do a
thing because it's good for my mind like
it clears my head that that exercise
don't work like that for me exercise is
a thing I have to get through like
eating a raw vegetable which I
never do or church you know it's not
like something to be celebrated
it's not like I'm alive I I do enjoy
that time because I spend a lot of that
time writing and an effort to not think
about how badly it sucks
to you know be going up a hill
and sweating um I just fill that with
like you know what will Jay and Silent
Bob do next or
whatever but um you know Jennifer don't
have that luxury for for a little while
so I am uh I'm I'm uh I'm here I'm like
I'm just I'm holding all the
threads
together sitting on a throne not
really um trying to hold the fort down
and so that's what's happening in
my personal life that being said um my
wife afforded me the opportunity to go
see the Marvels this week so outstanding
yes she was she had some coverage so I
was like ching and I went to
see um so that's where what's going on
in in my my life uh just for the folks
who were like hey man are you gonna but
wait like I had to cancel Zach and Mar
screening last week that was supposed to
happen at SM Castle um I'm supposed to
be going out for for Smokin December 2nd
I don't think I'm gonna be able to make
it um so I think we're gonna have to
move that into January so if you're
looking at those events like I'm I'm
pretty much GNA be Los Angeles based for
for the next month until we get Jen to a
walking place
what you got to do yeah anyway how about
you uh not nearly as eventful I have not
moved into or out of any place um I have
not had to minister to anybody uh who
needs intensive care I've uh I've just
been working I've just been writing I've
just been I got some comic book
that I owe um I'm we're we're in the
like proofing of colors and letters
phase on the Mace Windu book which is
always fun where I just cut half of what
I wrote Because I don't need it anymore
for those who are like b w book Mark's
working on Star Wars I am they
they called me from Marvel or Dark Horse
Marvel from Marvel look at that not
only is he working on Star Wars he's
working for Marvel on Star Wars look at
that every now and again you are you are
walking talking Disney plus my friend
that's
what uh yeah which I'm now paying more
for than I used to
um because we all are for everything um
but yeah man that's been about it and
you know Hollywood is kind of gearing
back up to life you know kind of getting
back up to speed so some projects that
had lay dormant for uh for six months or
so that are now kind of have some life
again contracts are being drawn up and
papers being signed so those are all
good things man all good things
I yeah we're back back to work kids the
as you know like we'll probably talk
about in the news but the writer strike
uh ended first and now the zag strike is
over as well indeed well potentially but
that is also a thing to talk about they
have yet to
ratify indeed um but before we get into
the meat of the hour slash two hours
slash three hours SL however long you
have until the the Bell goes off in the
in the upstairs Chambers requiring your
presence I've been listening I've got
that's why periodically be looking to my
left just to see if the cell phone has
lit up with a would you stop
talking about movies you had nothing to
do with and minister to my
[Laughter]
sick would you watch my ass for me
please I mean sure yeah it's what we
here for um we should uh we should pay
some bills yeah hell yeah kids this here
episode of fat man
beyond where we talk about about getting
old and busting hips and like that
uh is sponsored by the good Folks at
fume fume man I'm gonna send you there
right now go to
uh fume uh head to trif nume.com as I
read you some copy TR yfu m.com
and use the
code fat to save 10% off when you get
the journey pack to today Journey pack
comes with three unique flavors and a
new version two fume to help Kickstart
your positive habits man that's TR fume
TR R YF m.com and use code fat man to
save an additional
10% on your order today man be smart
don't start kick the habit put it out
before it puts you out man all phrases
we've heard a hundred times yet we still
continue to do bad
habits um yeah true yeah you know like
it's I I'm reminded of that uh there's a
great John meany bit where he talks
about watching iced tea on on Special
Victims Unit just rattle off things that
are bad for you like it's like betting
on the ponies it's like when you eat too
much and you make yourself vomit it's
like it's like when you when you scratch
too many lottery tickets it's just like
yeah like anything that's bad for you
that you want to try and stop any haveit
you want to get rid of try fume it'll
help our sponsor fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits that consume far too many of
us fume is a natural diffusive device
that uses plants and behavioral signs to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one fume is not a vape it
is a non-electronic device designed to
transform your habits see I got one here
they gave me one they sent me one too
but I've been
moving back and forth yeah I don't know
where it is yeah there's no batteries in
here there's no button to press up
there's no Lighty lights it is just a
little cartridge that you put stuff in
inhale it I got all these flavors here I
got raspberry lemon I got orange vanilla
I got Maple pepper I got crisp mint
these are not condoms I swear they look
like them sparkling grapefruit white
cranberry I I I'm not hitting it I
haven't hit it
yet is it is it it hit a b
uh sure I'll open him yeah try do it do
it do little guys here smells
good story that I I've probably told it
before but I always heard their story of
when the Rizza
met um Leonardo
Caprio um he was like what do you do and
Leonardo Caprio is like I'm an actor and
the Rizza reportedly said do
it favorite stories I hope it's
true um do
it what do you want me to do act
an actor do it Soliloquy
there's there's this amazing um clip I
think it's from The Graham Norton Show
maybe um where he he asks like Judy
Dench who's like just a guest on the
couch and is like the greatest living
Shakespearean actor or whatever he's
like do me some Shakespeare I like what
what do you want it's like I don't know
just Shakespeare me she's like
how about a Sonic and she launches in to
like whatever 40 lines of The
Shakespearean Sonet that's beautiful and
gorgeous and moving and deep and all the
things and the other two guests are like
is this magic like I didn't expect that
this would happen today but I've never
seen somebody say do it and then they do
it like oh she did it anyway anyway
uh instead of pots filled with
potentially har chemicals like a vape
fume uses cores infused with plants like
peppermint and cinnamon for delicious
natural flavors fumees new version 2
model is Snappy and tactile with an
adjustable airflow dial and a magnetic
end cap your fingers fingers will always
have something to
do look at that man indeed the
easiest way to stop a bad habit is to
switch to a positive one and fume is
designed perfectly to do just that it's
fumees goal to make switching easy and
even enjoyable they have thousands of
five-star reviews from people just like
you who successfully switched when other
Solutions just don't work so head to
tri.com and use code fat Mana checkout
to save 10% off when you get the journey
pack today Journey pack comes with three
unique flavors and the new version 2
fume to help Kickstart your positive
habits that's TR
f.com and use code Fatman to save an
additional 10% off your order today
thanks to the good Folks at fume for
sponsoring this episode we thank the
good folks of fume go to tr R YF
m.com kids right now show them your
appreciation they're sponsoring the show
indeed um all right
yeah let me get rid of this
copy by um let's
talk uh let's talk about Loki first
okay Loki came to an end they did six
episodes for the first five I was like
yeah I mean he's great I'll watch him do
anything and and I'll watch this but you
know it felt very like oh my God like
it's it's seems like it's the same story
all over again or whatever and then oh
my God episode six was like beautiful
stuck the landing
and wound up for me being like one of
the most powerful AR
character arcs in in the Marvel Universe
um Mar from Marvel Studios with a
beautiful haunting image imagery
uh at the end in the third act stunning
reversal for me where I'm like it
felt like for most of the time I'm like
I don't know if I'll remember any of
this and I will never
forget um how Loki
ends
uh you know we're on spoilers right MH
holy man him you know holding all
those uh all the the time what is the
timelines yeah the branches branches and
then turning it into a
tree the guy was introduced you know
when he's like I'm Loki of Asgard and
I'm what bured with glorious purpose
glorious purpose and
looking for a throne from the beginning
and to you you know that wasn't the
plan from the jump this just shows you
like in comics how a series of writers
will touch a character and the character
gets better and better and richer and
deeper
um they they found a way to make the
Loki story
story
matter you know and we got to see this
guy's whole Arc like I you oftentimes
when an artist dies I'll say to my wife
like wow we got to see their entire
career what an honor um it's sad because
that usually means that you know the
artist that passed is not very old right
if you're seeing their entire career but
we're getting old my wife shattered her
hip as just reported so yes
we're getting old so could be you know
that
maybe we're I don't know
people we're just seeing more of
people's
careers come to a close because the
people who were famous when we were kids
are now in their 70s
80s checking out or whatever the
but we got to see Loki's entire
career and in in you know marvel Studio
World obviously in comics it's a whole
different
Affair and what they did did with that
character was was insanely satisfying
and beautiful like what a you know often
times in comics you'll take a
beloved you know villain and turn him
into an anti-hero like Wolverine or Lobo
or you know so forth and such
like they they did it successfully I
thought with Loki and and hit an ending
that to me was like oh my God this is
one of the best things I've ever seen in
in in 15 years or whatever the of
Marvel making St telling you I'm never
going to forget the ending of that it
was really beautiful I had to
watch it twice just the ending to be
like did they really just do
that and I know like you know everyone's
like he's the god of stories you
idiot but I'm like I get that
but nobody you tell me you saw that
coming like you know but by episode five
I guess you could start to see the hints
of it but I I thought it was in
incredibly
Bittersweet just great writing wonderful
Direction because visually stunning
watching him gather all those
branches and in Herculean effort
him having you know they introduced the
series episode one season one
was um what was it called same title
glorious
purpose or something and this episode
was also the same title H um you know
oroboro Oro boring the whole
thing
um it's
so you know you're like oh my God this
guy figured out like they
let this character
grow tremendously and still like you
know got what he always wanted and a
throne but just didn't know what was
going to be attached to it didn't know
that he'd be at the end of time
alone but the moment where he's like I
know what God what kind of God I to be I
thought was so moving and I
didn't see it coming man I honestly
thought he was gonna kill Sylvie
I'm like well he'd be he'd be it'd be
excused at this point like he tried
centuries of other things but
instead he sacrificed
himself um beautiful beautiful ending to
that to a story that I thought was like
as it's good but man that ending is
great great episode you
um I I'd been struggling a little bit a
little bit about how to feel about it
because I remember when it ended when
the finale ended I was like angry at
first I was like I because I love what
happened to
Loki I just hated the road we had to
take to get there because so much of
that road felt like we didn't really
need to walk down it you know like this
could have been the seventh episode of
season 1 and ended the exact same way um
because it doesn't really start to cook
until you're back with he who remains
and you're back talking about you know
who's going to do this who's going to
who's going to keep control of the
universe who's going to make sure that
the trains run on time like they spent
five episodes trying to get me to care
about a bureaucracy that I just never
really did um they tried to get me to
care about Victor timley and I never
really did um you know I'm always here
for Owen Wilson and Mobius and I love
that character and more I love the two
of them together but it seemed to start
to drift away from that even though you
go back and you see him as a jet ski
selling you know single dad
um that was never it was never the
emotional core between him and Loki that
I kind of was looking for um but once
you're with he who remains once you're
with the unsolvable problem of you know
do you let Sylvie die or do you like
what happens to the universe and his
solution to that problem is the one that
no one ever thought that a Loki would
take like that's kind of great you know
and all of that imagery at the end and
all that stuff is kind of it's echoing
and It's haunting and it's it's a
different heroic finale than he got in
Infinity War which is the other time
that Loki has gone from villain to Hero
um you know it's not the first time
we've seen him redeem himself it's the
it's now the second time but he's now
taking the responsibility for others on
his shoulders in a way that he hadn't
before um I just I thought it was I
thought it was pretty great I just the
season itself did not work for me um and
so it's hard for a finale to feel like a
culmination of a season um in which it
it almost had nothing to do with what
came before in a way in that it only
starts working when you show up again at
the end of time with he who remains
talking about branching and multiverses
you know and then you have that little
Koda at the end like do the other kings
you know know who they are have have
there have there been any issues with
any of the other Kang variants like well
there was a minor Uprising in the 616
but we seem to have the people there had
put that down you know like
it's again like it so much of that felt
like it could have been a movie um you
know or a a TV movie finale for that
first season episode s is what it felt
like um but you know all that said him
on that throne with the world tree
behind him you know yrail from the old
Norse mythology um that's great that's
great mean Dave and chck goes I hope
there's a timeline with a happy Mark who
got an episode seven Loki season show
only Earth Earth
212 um what did you think of the uh
ending though um yeah I mean I I I dug
it I dug it like it it is weird to be
thinking about it in in in relation to
the larger multiversal story that Marvel
is telling um what this means for a
potential Kang dynasty movie um which
there was there was some reports that
came out this week that there may or may
not actually be a Kang dynasty movie
there's all this convers ation about do
we have to move away from Kang is like
does the Jonathan majors of it all you
know does the fact that Kang never
really platformed as a larger bad guy um
do we even go down that road do we just
skip the secret Wars and the only
confirmation that is that the the writer
for the Kang movie a guy named Jeff
lovess I think um is no longer writing a
Kang movie um whether or not he's guy
that wrote qu man right he was a writer
yeah so whether or not that means
they've just replaced him with somebody
else whether that means that they're
they're re-examining their commitment to
Kang as a villain um I don't know I
don't know but you could watch the end
of this of of Loki season 2 and be like
well all right so they dealt with all
the ks then kangs are fine we've got it
kangs are in the corner they said
something about too at the end sorry I
got to get a plug my computer's
Dy um they said something about it at
the end where they were like put the
folder on the desk and they're like uh
you know he don't know and
there was a some Kang activity
in 616 or whatever and they were
talking about Quantum
Mania and I'm still so nerdy that that
excited me I was like know they were
talking about but they seem to have
minimized the K threat to the place
like uh he we won't be hearing from in
anytime soon or some s right you know
and also like the way Marvel deals with
multiverses is always kind of slap Dash
which is even in Loki all of the
variants of Loki are not Tom Heston
they're like there's Richard E Grant
there's an alligator there's Sylvie
there's all of these other lokis that
look nothing like Tom Heston so you
could have a Kang that looks nothing
like Jonathan major and it's just
another king just because we saw a
Stadium full of kangs in a closing
Credit in a credit sting for quantam
Mania does not mean that that is how it
has to be um there's a version of this
whole story where Ren Slayer is a is a
Kang variant who just didn't know it um
and so that if if I have to have boooo
and baa raw as the villain of my Kang
dynasty movie twist my arm ouch that
would hurt so
bad um but yeah man I I feel like Marvel
you have to be be reactive and you have
to be somewhat Nimble and for as much as
an audience like like us likes it when
there's a plan and we love to see a plan
come together sometimes you got to Pivot
sometimes you just got to Bob and weave
and just because you gave a presentation
where you talked about the Kang Dynasty
coming in 2025 does not necessarily mean
that a Kang Dynasty has to come in
2025 or at
all jued
no no I'm not Juiced I don't know what
that is anyway let's keep
going people with my
problem um I'm just using a laptop
where I got like a breakout box in it
and why ain't this working
anyway enough so
Loki
um all right let's move on to the
marbles so move on to the Marvels uh I
saw it once how many times did you see
it I saw it twice I saw it once opening
night and then I went again with my wife
yesterday um and like I as I as I as
I've said on the internet um I had a
ton of fun watching this movie it
is light on its feet when it when it's
funny it's very very funny like I I'm
trying to remember the last time I
laughed as frequently as I did at a
Marvel movie maybe Ragnarok comes close
um you know I think the three leads are
incredibly engaging and when they're
together it's super fun I think this
version of Nick Fury is the version that
I like the best um the secret Invasion
Nick Fury was uh was not my cup of
tea um so much so that I didn't finish
secret
Invasion
um do we still have a Kev did you drop
out oh there he is I had to switch over
ah and
back um like the movie's got some
problems you know like the villain story
is a little weak um the way they kind of
platform that story is kind of
ineffective you know she's I suppose an
interesting I haven't seen her in
anything else before I don't think she
had that much to work with other than to
like be
British and that is
villainy more often than not in this
universe that's Tom Hon's wife in real
life right yeah yeah zi Ashton I think
her name is wild to be able to be like
you know what did you do at Marvel
today oh I did this you know but th this
movie makes it takes some really big
swings that for my money paid off like
the planet where the languages song and
everybody dances I thought was
incredibly charming and super fun and
was on screen for about as much time as
you could sustain that joke spoilers the
cat on the saber
station was inspired like to the point
where like you're playing memories
underneath it and that's the come on
guys this is great every time Iman V
valani is on the screen like it just it
comes to life like she's great she's
she's just she's nothing but energy and
joy and even when she's got to go sad
and even when she's got to go a little
bit dark all of that still plays
Bri Larsson is having a good time Tiana
Paris is having a great time um I like
yeah there's things I could complain
about there's things I just did complain
about you know the the the way they try
to play the origin story of what happens
on the cre home world for suspense feels
like a misdirect to me like open the
movie with what happened open the movie
with Captain Marvel going back to the
cre home World killing the Supreme
intelligence and somehow creating an
environmental disaster there's nothing
to be gained by making it a surprise
later on you know and so then we can
understand why she feels responsible for
other planets out there she we can
understand why she felt she to atone
before she could go home and meet Monica
Rambo for the first well not for the
first time but to to return to that
family you know like she had to earn it
and why because we saw what she did we
saw what might be generously considered
a War crime that she's trying to to to
make amends for so we understand that
stuff um you know it reminds me of a
little not the old movie but that aspect
remember Cosmic
Odyssey yeah vaguely DC Comics it was
what Jim Starin I think but it was by
um was it
Manola wow yeah I think it was Manola
drew it if I remember correctly I'm so
I'm sure somebody will tell me in the
comments but but uh in that they team up
you know to stop Dark Side yet
again and um at one point
uh who is it it's
um John Stewart Green
Lantern and I think is he teamed with a
Martian Manhunter if I remember
correctly
um you know they go to some
place some part of the Galaxy where
they're to protect this planet and John
Stewart the Green Lantern you know got
the ring as we I might explain
Green Lantern
audience event he was you know he's like
I got this are you kidding me the
ring bends to my will like I
could do anything with this
ring and they get to the planet and and
it's like ticking down there's a giant
bomb that's ticking down or whatever and
he's like oh my God we can get there at
the last second it won't matter
because I got the ring
and then uh he shows up and the bomb is
yellow and as we all know the green
lanter ring is powerless against
yellow because of that the entire
planet is
destroyed and he has to carry that I
think they took it through in some later
storylines but it was It was kind of
deep so that aspect of C of the Marvels
reminded me of like oh that was
a story that that impacted me when I was
a kid not saying I'm just saying right
the idea of like you're a space hero who
unwittingly causes the the the deaths
and uh and destruction of a lot that you
didn't intend to accidentally as people
are pointing out in in chat that led to
the Mosaic spinoff remember Mosaic
that's right that's right um what about
you
I you know look I had a good time I was
so glad it was short like and I'm not
not because I'm like Marvel but
just I I I like movies under two hours
man um unless you're endgame in which
case go nine but that that's the thing
this is not endgame this reminded me of
like the Ant-Man movies fun you know um
a good time the charming cast I I I like
Bri I like
um
um T what Tona Tana Paris yeah I mean
she was awesome in I we I've
liked her of course as my Granda but she
was awesome in they clone Tyrone did you
see that not yet it's on my list she was
also in madman back in the day if I
remember um so I you know I like her
and Iman vanani is that her name charm
City she was we loved the You
Know M Marvel series and stuff and uh so
watching her play fan girl in this movie
was everything I thought it was an odd
choice though that Carol was very short
with her
and and like like irritated by her it
seemed like she apologized later but I
don't I just not the approach I would
have taken but not not a criticism where
I'm like that ruined the movie I just
thought like you know what here I'm a
guy who deals with fans I would never
never be that
chilly a hardcore fan where
you're like bro it's like she's also
superpowered too it's
like
um you know the
villain kind of they didn't really give
the villain much to do other than
hold that stick again and
which I'm like wait a second why does it
have any power yeah like is are the
Infinity Stones back or
like
um but um you know there was it was
there was enjoyable stuff totally what a
movie should
be um in terms of like hey we went to
another planet we
escaped um the problem
is I you know well we clearly have
entered an era of superhero
fatigue not to mention the fact that
everyone's like hey man the first C
Marvel made a billion
point2
dollar um um I always thought and I
ain't against the other two marvels or
whatever the but I always thought
it was weird that your sequel to The
billion point2 grossing you know
movie was not called like Captain Marvel
2 or Captain Marvel the Marvels like it
just I I know I'm not saying this is why
it didn't do as well but if it were like
me I'd have kept cap Marvel in the
title
um again not I'm not saying and that's
why things didn't work out for him but I
always thought that was a weird not to
say like it was weird to include the
other two that was great but you're
squizing a movie with brand name
recognition that made over a billion
dollars like dropping half of your
title I it just seemed weird to me early
on but I was like I'm sure they know
what they're doing and again I don't
think that's the reason everything went
South but I don't think it
helped I
think Captain Marvel happened between
two Avengers movies like you know when
we were starred do you remember
after infinity War when you watched
everyone like dust off and you
were like what the and then Nick
Fury's pager had the Captain Marvel
symbol on and you were like she'll know
what to do you know that that movie was
insanely well positioned and I'm not
saying that's the only reason made money
but it's like you put it between
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
endgame and stuff and you're like this
character is going to play Big
role you know I I think it was always
going to be a daunting task to revisit
that same
number no matter how good or bad the
movie is I just think that was at a
period of time when like they could have
they could have put out Thor dark World
2 in that slot and it would have
did better than did am I crazy or no no
I think there was there was definitely
some inertia there was momentum that
that in the same way that when I think
it was Iron Man 3 came out after the
Avengers and it had like The Avengers
one and it also made like $1.2 or three
billion dollar for ant for Iron Man 3
and it's because it had like the halo
effect it was the oh sh it's like
Avengers 1.5 it's like I want more of
this this is the thing that gives me
more of it great um you know I think
Captain Marvel was sold incredibly well
you know the ad campaign for that movie
and it also came at a time when people
were hungering for for female
superheroes and like women showed up to
go see that movie because the ad
campaign was little girl standing up for
herself remember that that Montage they
had of like Carol Danvers as a kid in a
go-kart you know accident she stands up
and then C Danvers as a pilot who gets
out of an accident she stands up and as
Katherine Marvel as a hero when she
stands up And the tagline was like it
takes her and then they put the O at the
end of her to make hero and it's like it
was it was the thing that you go to a
studio for which is the marketing muscle
that can that can spread the word and
can spread it well and the ad campaign
for M Marvel or the Marvels was never
that good it never was it never found a
way to get you to care and it started to
feel desperate to the point when the the
final trailer half of it was from
endgame half of it was like remember
what Heroes were remember the last time
you saw Heroes and here's Captain
America and here's Tony Stark and here's
Nick Fury and here's it's like it just
felt like they were running away from
the movie and you know listen again I'm
not saying it's a great movie I really
enjoyed it I had a good time at it um
but I think it It suffers from a lot of
market conditions that did not help very
well It suffers from two out of the
three characters having been introduced
on television on Disney plus you know
and having you to have to remember that
or have seen that to know who Monica
Rambo is to know who M Marvel is M
Marvel like the lowest rated Marvel
Disney Plus show is the way that you got
into that character and so to expect
there to be any crossover there doesn't
really
hold uh
oh I was just going to say you also
don't have Brie Larson talking on any
talk shows because of a sag strike you
don't have the other actors on
Nickelodeon talking about it or whatever
kids watch you know can you imagine like
if you're you had um and I haven't
watched any of it because all I do is
Dad and run a bar but like if you had
all of those people out there on the
talk show circuit and on all of those
different things talking about how fun
this movie would be to bring your
daughter to like does that get me off of
watching Spidey and his amazing friends
and I take my daughter to see the
Marvels instead uh maybe but you didn't
have any star power pushing the
movie all you had was
editors at home cutting endgame footage
into so that could be a big maybe not a
big part of it but certainly has to play
into it let's
say you know
in like that promotion if they were able
to go out and promote it like actors
normally
do that you know for some reason
it double what they made this weekend
which was what 47 million yeah so that
would be 94 million still wouldn't be as
much as the first Captain Marvel made
and it would still be getting attacked I
would imagine by a bunch of folks um
Dave and chat pointed out wisely that
Marvel's uh still was number one at the
box office this weekend you know for as
much as everyone's like oh it was
the number one movie this week and set a
record for a female black director says
mean Dave absolutely right about that
yeah I mean it just it it seems like
there's and the online discussion about
this movie has been a little bit all
over the place um you know it seems like
this movie is the equivalent of the
T-shirt in Almost Famous you remember
that scene where they get the band
t-shirt and every face on it is blurry
and Jason Lee is like no man look it's
exactly what it's supposed to be and
Billy credup is like no this t-shirt
lets you say everything you've ever
wanted to say your looks are becoming a
problem I was the FR man you were the
guitarist with
Mystique um you know like there are
people who were like you know this is
what happens when you give a director
you know a second time director an
incredible raise or whatever like you
know she only had one other movie under
her belt which is also a lie but like
she didn't earn it and she only got it
because she's a black woman and blah
blah blah and it's like
no this is water Still Water CD I just
as I was unpacking I came across it it's
Jason Lee gave it to me if you're an
Almost Famous fan it's service fan Fever
Dog it's got every track they
ever recorded and Peter Frampton
did it or something uh no it was one of
the God it was one of the women from
heart Nancy Wilson I think no Peter
Frampton well Jason leee said he went to
rock and roll Camp with Peter Frampton
he was the he was the guy yeah but like
I think Nancy Wilson co-wrote she was
married to Cameron Cameron and she wrote
those
songs did she Peter Frampton was the
music The Rock and Roll guy who coach
the band though Jen Jen is too Almost
Famous as I am to Star Wars so I get
Yeah by by default uh yes you're both
right that's right isn't that why can't
why can't why
can't why can't the internet be like
that
Mark we're both right everybody's right
nobody here is wrong yeah it's like and
and the more more I remember that I
guess the better it would be I it's just
so yeah you know and also like there's
the The Narrative around Marvel has been
waiting for the thing to poke at you
know and and whether that narrative is
earned or not you know that's that that
is Up For Debate you know did I like
Ant-Man 3 no did I love Loki no you know
are there are there movies of the recent
you know whatever phase we're in phase
four or five that did not work for me
sure um are they at something of an
inflection point with where they're
going and where they've been and should
they have as to your point taken a break
after endgame and let us live with an
ending for a little while you know that
was never going to happen because again
once you buy a studio for $6 billion
you're going to squeeze every last dime
out of that studio even if the story is
asking for it to end all of those things
are true you know is the Marvel the
reason for any of it no is it is it a
symptom of any of it maybe maybe not you
know I think it's a relatively well-made
movie with a bunch of of actors who
performed very well um will it make
money if it cost $220 million and only
made 110 Global in its opening weekend
probably not you know it'll tap out a
$300 million and and then do what a
Disney movie or a Marvel movie will do
which is play on TNT and TBS and USA
from here until the end of time and
we'll be fine um is there an audience
who perhaps was trained that they can
see Marvel movies on Disney plus a month
or two after release maybe maybe I don't
know there's there's there's a lot of
theories about why it didn't work um
nobody knows for sure other than the
gender split and the audience was not in
its favor in that most of the people who
went to see it were men um I think only
35% of the audience was
female um so they did not even get the
audience that they should have been able
to count
on what do you think that's about I
think some of it is bad marketing I
think some of it is they just did not
speak to that audience they they didn't
find a way to make it necessary the way
that Wonder Woman was necessary the way
that the first Captain Marvel was
necessary and important important um I
don't know why the way the Black Panther
was important you know and granted
sometimes you can you can create and you
can ferment that kind of passion um and
sometimes you can't but all of those
other movies existed at a place at a
time where that was an answer to a
question which is why are there no
superhero movies about women like Wonder
Woman is one of your Holy Trinity and
you've got all these other movies you
don't have Wonder Woman and then you
give people Wonder Woman and it's pretty
good you know there's been 19 Marvel
movies and it took you this long to get
one about a female superhero and it's
Captain Marvel and I don't even like
Captain Marvel that much but I see the
answer and the question that it was
answering and so I get it um so yeah I
don't I don't I don't have a crystal
ball I don't have a magic Theory um I
just know that it's it probably deserved
better than it got and I think that's
some of the reasons why it got it have
nothing to do with its relative
quality
um it's uh it also just you know again
when Captain Marvel came out it was like
oh my God
this will have clues about
endgame like it's all feeding into like
endgame this movie didn't feel like it
was feeding into anything other than
itself Standalone story which should be
absolutely fine for a movie to stand
alone and it does and I I think it works
I know a lot of people don't like it and
I've seen a lot of hyperbole online
like worst movie ever made I don't feel
that but I stretch of the
imagination
um but it you
know I don't I
it's I I
think this they put this movie into
production at a time when I think they
were like we could do anything MH
they'll come see anything like this
movie was in put in production preo
right I think so yeah like they started
that it feels like it's very late I mean
this was supposed to happen before
secret Invasion this following secret
invasion is weird because Nick Fury is
so Dow in secret Invasion here he's just
like you know having a good time um so
scheduling Co affected it and whatnot
and you know what are you going to do
they spent $200 million it said making
the movie I read an article so it's not
like like you know they can back girl it
or something like that I'm sure they
didn't think it was like you know from
what I've read
online um based on you know the that
book that you read the yeah
MCU they were shocked by Quantum Mania
over they were like what do you mean
people don't like it and this movie was
already done near done so I
think you know they shot that post-edit
thing felt kind of
recent um but I I think you know
they I I I think you're probably GNA see
a lot of well I mean what's his name
Eiser already said he's like hey man
we're gonna rain it in quality not
quantity yeah I think this is definitely
going to put that in the overdrive um I
think we're g to see the plans
accelerated like you said I think Kang
Dynasty goes away and I think they're
like we got to get to that reboot movie
Man the one we got to get to secret warh
so we can just dump everything
and start with a clean slate or whatever
the they want to do and I think
that for the most part the like Marvel
Disney plus
experiment um is kind of over you know
the idea that you could make things that
happen on the TV shows as important as
the things that happen in the movies and
it all exist as one big story that
everybody ingested it's like y I said
Eisner and me I
my bad yeah that shows you how old I
am you know like I I just it between
between the idea that Kang who was you
know introduced in Loki and then went to
Quantum Mania and nobody seemed to care
between these two you know Ms Marvel and
and and Captain Rambo introduced in You
Know M Marvel and W division
respectively um and then brought into
the movies to sort of stand side by side
like that kind of platforming just is
not working for them you know and so we
don't have that much more TV stuff down
the plag we get what if season two which
apparently is is debuting this December
um Iron Hart is in the can probably to
release sometime next year Ekko is on
the way you know dropping I think you
know the end of this year the beginning
of next Daredevil I think is starting to
get back on track with new writers and
new directors and all that stuff but
like
after that I think that pipeline that
had been so
huge is is getting throttled because
Iger also said pull back too much Marvel
you're diluting the brand by putting so
much stuff out there and not enough of
it is great um so do half as much you
know we'll see if there's still going to
be a Thunderbolts movie we'll see if
there's still going to be an armor Wars
movie we'll still see if there's again
King Dynasty seems to be hanging by a
threat if it exists blade seems to be
hanging by a threat if it exists you
know it's Marvel is in a state of flux
and it's and that is not a a a
pejorative statement at all like they
are in a time of change where they need
to decide who they're going to be and
more importantly what's the story
they're going to tell because again
there was no compelling reason to see
the Marvels the way there was to go see
Captain Marvel and without it it's
really hard to make this kind of thing
work yeah because then you
know I I don't think like and you know a
lot of people online are like the
problem is they went woke and stuff like
that I I don't think that doesn't feel
like it to me I just feel like there was
so much content which admittedly I was
like Yay as much content as possible um
forgetting that like there's there's one
person overseeing it all and if you
stretch that person very thin and all
those creative teams thin you don't have
you know the storytelling that you had
when they were kicking off and they were
hungry I mean you know it's been well
I've been accused of it online for years
like you're not good anymore you
were good with clerks and now
you're older and you suck and you know I
don't agree with that
but but I'm not the one buying tickets
I'm the one selling tickets so you know
I think they've
just is pretty tough act to
follow that end game Infinity War
endgame double punch the whole world was
invested in Thanos and like that I
just you know I
think I think if I was in charge at
Marvel I'd start making fewer and
cheaper movies but that's just me yeah I
mean the Marvel is at $200 million like
why like I understand it like other
worlds and special effects and all that
and I'm sure the pandemic and blah
blah blah and for the record man like
who's director neand deosta yeah better
filmmaker than me I never could have
made the Marvels
so I'm not like saying like oh my God
here's where she up you
know
clearly at this level everyone knows
what they're doing and and the movie is
not poorly
directed no some of the action scenes
somebody know what to do with the camera
clearly the director knows what to do
with the camera yeah I mean some of the
action scenes some of that fight
choreography is as good as I've seen it
in Marvel outside of a Captain America
movie like when they went hard like they
turned Captain America into an MMA
superhero um which is great man remember
the first time you saw him in Winter
Soldier he's booking yeah
through the boat when he lands when he
jumps out lands and and it's
like oh my God they've redefined this
guy yeah when he's when he's taking on
bat Rock the leiper he like takes his
helmet off and puts the shield down and
it's like right let's fight and
they fight and they like that stuff is
great this had a lot of inventiveness to
it you know that first fight scene when
they're in the the uh the KH household
and like bouncing in and out these
characters and through ceilings and
roofs and in like it was great like I I
had a blast with it but to your point
it's not her fault um I don't think it's
anybody's fault I think it's it's this
this was going to be it was either going
to be one or another one just like it
that that
the momentum caught up with it or the
lack of momentum caught up with it and I
was like
well do you think
um
they ever get the magic back
or is it Like Comics like it's it's odd
but this kind of of happened this all
happened before it's like that's this
all happened before it will all happen
like in
comics like in the 990s and the ODS with
f foil covers and like the
Marvel Universe stable of characters was
massive and claremont's fantastic but
impenetrable run on the X-Men meant that
new people weren't jumping on board they
had like multiple X-Men titles
and like
that you know it just if it's it's like
you can
see like this there are there's a
blueprint and I know that like in the
movies they they like the comics for the
characters and the and Origins but then
they like to do their own stories and
stuff but you know what is that called a
a narrative culdesac when you just enter
it and like you know
it's
I I got powers this person's mad at me
we're gonna fight and I'm a hero like
you know certain
point you're just telling that similar
story over and over again and they did
that in in comics as well now in comics
you can go way more in way many more
directions because it's not as expensive
as a movie it's not $200 million to do
an issue of Captain Marvel or
something like that but but you
know I'm not saying like superheroes
have run their course but like
the general public seems to get it yeah
you know and I think when it was on the
rise when we were all buying in and all
of that momentum and Goodwill and
inertia like what are we doing we're
building to this we're building to this
how does this fit into this piece oh my
God we're building a giant you
know camar Dy of story and it's awesome
and then once you get to the top of the
mountain you're like great we did it can
we all go home now it's like no there's
another eight things you have to watch
and we're going to climb Another
Mountain which we haven't told you what
it is or where it is or what's at the
top of it but we're climbing that
mountain so come along with us and
you're like okay you know it's like in
the comics like Wolverine was the star
of like seven different Marvel Comics at
one point because he was the one that
worked you know he was the hero that
people liked and then suddenly you're
just like how much Wolverine can I take
how many X-Men titles can I buy you know
what what is it giving me back for my
investment in it and I feel like we're
at the point where the the the
continuity of it the connected Universe
of Marvel that had been such a boom has
become a burden and I think that the
Marvels is when nobody wanted to do the
homework Cav 20 in chat says Marvels has
similar problems with love and thunder
and Quantum Mania it feels Rewritten and
reshot at infinitum and it kind of
messes up things it does well or should
be doing well fun but
incoherent I wish I was really smart
about movies say a guy has made his
living in movies for the last 30 years
um but I I you know I can't express
myself like
that you know I mean I don't I don't
know
if as much as I'm a filmmaker I still
remain a movie fan and as much as I make
movies for a living I part of my brain
refuses to believe that and I still
behave like a member of the audience and
I'm not I don't have a high bar you know
like it's it's not like man you really
gota tell an original story to
satisfy me I'm
oddly s saded by the same
ridiculous superhero story over and over
again I've said many times why that is
and that's because I love the idea of a
story where when the worst thing in the
world is happening and everybody's
running from it one or the small band of
colorfully dressed folks are running at
it that's like I'll I'll read I'll watch
that story read that story over and over
again I'm a sucker for it stuff doesn't
mean I don't like other things but
that's my comfort food like I love that
kind of story um but could be that like
you know I've been I've been enjoying
that story for the better part of 50
years com book form and now you know I
got to see it all again on the big
screen could be that the general public
that like jumped in for like the
excitement of building to Thanos and
endgame like once they got to endgame
they were like all right well like the
same way you watch a Netflix show and
you're like I did it all all
right now I'm gonna do something else
you know and I think there'll always be
an audience I just think that audience
is you know they're going to be a lot
more selective they used to go to
everything
and now it's like you better give them
something they've never seen before and
the problem is most of these stories is
something one has seen before that's
Winter Soldier was such a breath of
fresh air because you're like well it's
a superhero movie but it's not it's
comic book movie but it's it's it's kind
of like you know three days of the
Condor or something like that so when
they gen genre
mashed I I think the results were
thrilling you know because then you
didn't know what movie you were
necessarily getting and it wasn't
following what you assumed it would be
their sequels didn't necessarily feel
like sequels it just felt like ongoing
chapters in a
story um I don't know yeah no I think I
think you're right I think that that
when when they used to be kind of you
know we're doing Star Wars with
guardians and we're doing a heist movie
with anman and we're doing political
Thrills doing The Parallax view with
Captain America like like those were all
different speeds like we were doing the
airbrush side of a van with Thor
Ragnarok um all of that stuff felt
somewhat unique and somewhat different
but they all had a a pull to them
because they knew they were building
towards something now these movies all
feel like superhero movies when they all
didn't
before you know and you know again I
don't I don't know I don't know we are
just on chair detectiving what what the
issue is um is there some
maybe is there a course correction
coming from Marvel probably you know
but it is it is sad that the Marvels had
to be the one that uh that took the the
brunt of it that they were the first
through the door of an audience not just
being willing to go see
everything um
yeah and and maybe there maybe
it's there's I don't know there's a
shift it ain't just marvel you know I
know this is what we're talking about
because the Marvels just came out and
there was that article a few weeks ago
and whatnot but it's like you know DC
saw
some little traction this year you know
superhero fatigue is is a real thing not
for me I like that but seems like for
the general public so if I was going to
do anything to fix it if I was in charge
I would just be like let's make less and
make them
cheaper yeah you know I mean nobody says
that there's horror
fatigue even though not every horror
movie is great not every horror movie is
even good but they're cheap enough and
even if they're bad they make their
budgets back by and large and so we'll
take seven or eight of them a year
because a they're all different stories
for the most part even if they're all
slasher movies they're all different
kinds of slashers and B they scratch in
it the the inherently human like gangli
basil DNA in in everybody that likes to
be scared and so they give us that thing
you know what what's the thing that
superhero movies do for us you know do
do they give us hope do they allow us to
believe you know then the movies that we
make that want to Vector on that kind of
pleasure Center ought to do that
too and if they're cheaper you can swing
harder on the ones that are just
weirder
um uh there was another comic book movie
that came out this week but I haven't
seen it yet um me neither the Fincher
movie The Killer yeah it's based on what
a French comic book right yeah of the
same
title fast Bender Magneto and
FY I gotta watch that I've been we
I guess we're done talk about the
Marvels talk about the Marvels um but
while we're talking briefly about
Netflix um I have been shouting from the
top of every Hill I can find that Bluey
Samurai on Netflix is maybe the best TV
show I've seen all year um it is written
and created by Michael Green he of uh
Blade Runner 2049 and
Logan um and his wife Amber noomi I
think is how you pronounce her name it
is the most beautiful animated show I've
seen in quite a while the writing is so
sharp and tight and built on
character character character that it's
it's annoying how well done it is
because it makes it difficult to want to
go and write things for yourself once
you see somebody do it so well um it's
violent as it's sexy as um
it's tragic as
hell um all of The Voice work is is
through the roof topnotch they spent
money on this it looks it
reminds me of Arcane which was another
um Netflix animated show where you know
every animator that I knew looked at it
with Envy because nobody could spend
that much money but they had video game
money so they spent it um blueeye
Samurai was a we're just going to take
forever to do it we're going to take
five years to make this show and it's
going to look like we spent every one of
those five years drawing um I cannot
recommend it highly enough you know it
is is for sure going to be on my end of
the year top 10 list um I'm looking for
an excuse to watch it again um but it's
it's
phenomenal Chen would like it quite a
bit is that right it
is I think she dig it the most Bobby to
pop
breaks and someone
named um CZ Vegas wrote literally the
exact same thing so even they either
they copy and pasted it from some or
they're running two accounts but they
said how come the boys and gen V are
doing so well if it was fatigue it is
not fatigue it is good writing and
stories female leads and LGBT characters
and no one cares because the show is
Well written I guess he's talking about
gen v um yeah but but these are apples
and oranges like genv is not competing
at the box office like
like the Marvels which is what we were
talking about um and also like we don't
know the numbers on genv or the boys so
you know for all you
know fewer people watch it than
saw the Marvels we we have no
criteria just because you've seen it and
some of your friends have seen it
doesn't mean the whole world all seen it
but also
nobody's like why is the internet like
that it's just like it ain't what you
said it's what I say and it's like I I
didn't say that we had the
answer but
nobody's yeah I get it yes if these
things were better written and but
like at the same time you
know marvel had a brand that was almost
bulletproof like everyone just went
because it was Marvel mhm was
talking about what happened there um but
I look forward to watching genv I love
the boys um
yeah you haven't watched it yet I
haven't watched it I haven't watched it
I haven't watched
Invincible yet I haven't watched
Invincible season 2 I loved Invincible
season one yeah one is great like I
haven't seen season two yet I watched
the
crown the new season the crown which I'm
sure this whole audience is like
yeah Diana what else did I watch I
watched um the new Emma Stone Nathan
Fielder show yeah the
curse so up yeah I've heard I
haven't seen it yet is
is you you've not seen anything else
like it that's for sure um seems to be
like a meditation
on on uh not just like you know
those Home Improvement HGTV but
like you know fake altruism or something
like that but it is well done and
there's a moment in it where
dude whips out the smallest you've
ever
seen and I was like that's how you make
a first
episode that's where wrong on Masters of
the Universe Revelation Mark we
should have opened the first episode
with a tiny you gotta hang down man
if you're not hanging dong I don't know
what hang a tiny one that gets people
talking whole nation's talking about
this D
um yeah I watched that what else did I
watch started watching murder at the end
of the world but I I I'm I'm I'm gonna
like Jennifer has been so appreciative
that I've been spending so much time
with her she's like we can watch
something that you want to watch and I I
think it I I don't know if I need to be
like let's watch the boys and then watch
gen V or can I just take a right to
genv um I mean that is also a we can
watch what you want to watch no we can't
yeah that's actually not true at all you
know what i' like to watch now I'd like
to watch Virgin River a very quiet show
about people living in a small
Midwestern
Town um RPM in chat said something
interesting Marvel banked on infinite
growth and that's not sustainable of the
top 10 most expensive films of all time
three of them are Avengers
flicks
yeah uh Invincible I do want to watch
that I can't convince her to watch that
with me I don't think she doesn't really
go for animation um but I will watch
Invincible because I love one and watch
if you watch you should watch a couple
of episodes of blueeye Samurai and then
tell me the Jen wouldn't love
it done I'll take your suggestion and it
took me months to go for train
to Busan years years and when I finally
saw it I was like you know what marks
he's got a point he's on
something um all right should we do some
news yeah I guess we've talked about
everything we can talk about somebody in
chat was like didn't talk about the
Beast yeah we did it's like one of the
first talked about yeah before we did
the ad we're talking about Beast yeah
truly um yeah let's dive into the news
Man Mark used to do News Kids he
was a newsound and now these days well
he left the news behind except whenever
we're doing fat man beyond that's when
he puts on his press hat with a little
card in it and goes back to
gather news to give to y'all and usually
it's news that other people have done
first regardless he's not breaking news
let's be honest Mark's not out there
muck raking and like that I am not
calling sources I am not not hanging
outside of hospitals but he did the
heavy lifting and pulling a few links
before show so there it is Mark's here
with the news hit him Mark gotta
qualifies uh so the the the news since
we last podcasted that has uh shifted
the firmament in entertainment the most
is that the uh the SAG Afra actor strike
um has officially been called off that's
the biggest news Reacher season
two trailer that's the news my
friend dude when he kicks the front of
that car in the
airbag was like oh yes nicely done I
live in I fully support 100% the reacher
verse Man the reacher oh my God him
like just punching through that
car pulling that dude out I was
like he's back he's back can't wait
Batman without the mask anyway yes the
SAG strike uh after strike finally came
to an end kids yes um and it looks like
they got a lot of things they wanted
correct looks like they got a lot of
things they wanted I don't I don't have
the entirety of what they what they got
in their negotiations with the with the
studios because a not all of it is
public yet the entire long form of the
proposed deal has not been made public
at least to you know me um and so here's
here's sort of a bullet list of like six
things the actors got that they were
looking for um
and the thing to remember is that in a
negotiation you don't get everything you
want you make progress you get you know
you you move the dial on the things that
you want but maybe that dial doesn't go
all the way into the zone you were
hoping for what about the writers did
the writers get everything we wanted no
there were some things that we also
couldn't couldn't really you know push
over the hill we wanted feature
screenwriters to get weekly salaries
instead of on the sort of installment
basis that didn't happen we wanted
stronger protections on AI we got okay
protections on AI same thing with the
actors um you know we wanted more
transparency on streaming numbers um we
got some transparency on streaming
numbers um I think it's always you know
a give and a take um and hopefully you
take more than you give um so for the
actors for sag their minimum
compensation increases performers will
earn a 7% wage increase effective
immediately and then next next year it's
a 4% increase and then 2025 it's a 3.5%
increase background actors stand-ins and
photo doubles will immediately earn an
11% wage increase followed by the same
four and 3.5% increases uh in uh in 2024
and 2025 which is awesome everybody gets
paid more great streaming bonuses the
new contract calls for actors to earn a
success payment along with the usual
residuals if they work on streaming
projects that attract a significant
number of viewers the success Matrix is
determined by the by let's see total
number of domestic streaming hours over
the first 90 exhibition days divided by
the total runtime of the blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah whatever
it's a bonus that you get that you
didn't get before if you had a show that
did incredibly well on Netflix or Apple
TV or whatever um and part of what
everybody wants is to share in the
success of the work that they do um
disclosure on viewership stats um let's
see on high budget streaming Productions
streaming producers will be required to
disclose the total number of hours the
content was streamed both in the US and
and Canada and abroad for each quarter
so that you can you can see if you're
being compensated compared to the show's
distribution of popularity here's the
big one limits on artificial
intelligence film and TV producers must
obtain consent from actors to create and
use their digital replicas as well as
specify how they intend to use that
digital likeness actors are entitled to
compensation at the usual rate for the
number of days they would otherwise have
been paid
for to do the work being performed by a
digital
replica which is pretty good it's not
great but it's pretty good what some
actors are hoping for was no digital
replicas no AI none of it at all period
but that doesn't seem like a thing that
the studios were going to countenance
and so limits instead of a ban um number
five minimum number of background actors
the new labor contract requires that an
increased number of background actors be
hired on Union terms in the west coast
to equal the minimum number in New
York um and relocation bonuses
performers in series who have to
relocate for work will be entitled to a
maximum relocation benefit of up to
$5,000 a month for 6 months a 200%
increase on the previous
amount all of that sounds great there's
a lot more in there because the actors
had some 30 different points that they
were trying to negotiate the writers had
eight and so this is only six of those
30 that had some motion and some
movement um what is left to happen is
the actors can vote to ratify or reject
this deal um when the writers got to
vote on their deal it passed with a 98%
I believe um and uh it is unclear if the
entirety of sag will be as unanimous um
there were there were you know 12,000
members of the wga there were 160,000
members of sag and a body that large
doesn't always pull the boat in the same
direction and there's there's some
debate online if you follow any actors
you've rather seen some say I'm voting
yes some say I'm voting no and here's
why a lot of it is based on the AI
stuff um a lot of it is based on some
general unhappiness that they didn't get
more than they got um I have no stake in
this fight other than to
say maybe I hope we were not premature
in in rescheduling Productions um and
letting actors go back out promote their
material and and and you know suddenly
saying hey everybody who was on pause
going back to work I hope that that was
not a a uh a premature work
stoppage because if they don't
ratify then they go back on
strike
um man this industry needs to go back to
work yeah you know and there's all these
you know I've seen all these stories
about the
economic um hole that has been blown
into the economy both
nationally and uh and in the state of
California because of the work stoppage
and it's billions of
dollars um that it's going to take some
time to rebuild that it's going to take
some time to get everybody back to work
and by everybody it's not just actors
and writers or directors it's everybody
who makes anything that's dependent on
movies or TV it's craft services it's
set Builders it's VFX artists it's sound
designers it's costume designers it's
everybody we're down 25%
sales at scum from the fact that
nobody's been
working
wow and I have heard it is from Santa
Barbara to San Jose because the people
who would usually vacation in Santa
Barbara on the weekends now don't have
the money to go on vacation and eat out
in Santa Barbara So bars and
restaurants all all up and down Southern
California are are down what I've heard
is like we're down 25% some 30
35% since since the strike so it's
beyond even just industry it's trickles
out to everything
else yeah that's the thing it's like
it's not just you know some people
online are like oh actors want
more money or whatever or you know
the rich get Richer there a lot of
people in this business yours yours
truly as well uh did not get rich making
movies you don't make get rich making
Kevin Smith movies I assure you
um and there are a lot of people that
make a living making movies but you know
don't get rich doing it and stuff um and
and then there are people that have
nothing nothing to do with the industry
who still count on people in the
industry like all those
restaurants around the you know the
studios and must be severely um if
JC like JC at least has got a bar so
sooner or later people are like you know
how I get over this a drink you know and
they come out and get their
drink on and stuff but yeah man it's
it's it's a lot of folks that are
affected by this beyond the obvious and
um and
it's time for everyone to get back to
work yeah like when they say that La is
a company town you know the company the
business the industry is is movies and
TV and it does touch
everyone everyone and so the sooner we
get the the engine back up and running
um the better it will be for everybody
um that is not me pressuring any actor
to do a thing he doesn't want want to do
um you have to vote your conscience you
have to vote you know with an eye on
reality and an eye on Hope but you know
it's uh it's it's hurting lots and lots
of people and again we are not hurting
lots and lots of people the wga or sag
the studios were hurting lots and lots
of people by not coming to terms with us
far far sooner than they did mean Dave
in chat said porn's still doing good
though is it though like I know that you
know obviously not affected by either of
those
strikes I thought like the porn
industry wasn't
quite like the same as when we were like
is vivid still making porn and stuff or
is it now just all homemade stuff um I I
think like only fans is doing the thing
only fans kind of took the place of a
lot of professionally made stuff no yeah
I mean I don't I don't know what
subscription numbers are like for vivid
or or or Hustler or any of those you
know merchants and stuff I know that the
tube sites like you know whatever up
porn or pornhub or whatever it is where
you can watch porn for free has uh has
taken a little bit of the sting out of
all right I'm going to give these guys
30 bucks a month to watch porn when I
can just watch this over here for
nothing you know the
entrepreneurial desire and and and sort
of Ingenuity of of performers who go on
on only fans like yeah hell yeah it's
like patreon for porn like here's the
kind of porn that I want I will pay you
for it and everybody goes home happy and
then gets happier and happier and
happier is that what happens at only
fans
yeah it's not all porn though no no but
it's
mostly it's like Tyler Posey's on he
ain't do a porn is he I mean I don't
know what Tyler POS is up to probably
not but even still like you're paying a
monthly fee for access to a person that
you like and that person will do
whatever like I'mma read you some
poetry cuz I'm Tyler posie this
is what we're doing you know I'm going
just give you it's like Instagram that
you're paying for with even Instagram
started doing which is it could
subscribe to people's you know special
subscription feed if you wanted to I saw
a uh story about some teacher who was
had an only fans and like the school
found out and
and I guess she was like it I don't
give a because she was making like
10 times what she made as a
teacher me and you gotta open up an only
fans where we just take our
shirts off and tease
nipples got me an audience that right
just like we don't want to penetration
but we like a lot of nipple work between
middleages just Hammer those
nips
dude what would you pay for that kids
what's that worth how much of
month some withered acorns worth
of nipples and just whing on
godamn day
truly I uh we gotta keep up with the
kids
Mark hey kids you want to see these
nipples I got we got to go where the
kids fear to go middle-aged men working
each other's nipples they're
terrified
we could quarter that market man yeah
what's the name of it it's fat man a
Beyond yeah beyond beyond they after
join us on our patreon Batman Beyond
Beyond where me and Mark stop talking
about Marvel and start marveling at each
other's
nipples then be on after dark we could
play superhero music in the
background this week I'm tweaking Mark
nipples John Williams Superman score
here we
go oh Alan sylvestri will cry when I S
them
[Laughter]
nipples H the money we can all make I
know it's what it seems to be
all about him we're leaving this
money on the table this nipple money
it's nuts I know we're leaving nickels
and nickels worth of money on the yes
all adds up them nickels you no it could
catch on in a freak way you know John
Oliver talks about it and suddenly
people like I Gotta See this is that the
guy from
clerks work
now oh let me tell you about Silent
Bob's
nipples uh what other news we got bag
strike essentially potentially being
over fingers fingers crossed um Warner
Brothers uh has killed and then spared
apparently coyote versus Acme this is an
interesting story um because first it
sounded a lot like the backgirl story we
were like hey we got a finished movie
but it we're not gonna put it out
because it's gonna cost too much money
for us to put out and we're just gonna
take the ride off on this movie and the
filmmaker was heartbroken and a lot of
people jumped in as well other
filmmakers having nothing to do with it
to just be like why would you ever make
a movie at Warner Brothers ever again
knowing that they could just
shove it for a tax write off yeah you
know espe Matt Zer sites had a series of
tweets which I really enjoyed where he
said like okay if they're getting a $30
million tax write off I think he
retweeted somebody else's tweet I don't
think it his original idea but the idea
was since we're paying since we the
taxpayers are that's that's 30 million
write off we absorb
that they said why not make the film
public domain or like available
to the
taxpayer which I was like yeah
you're right man like don't just delete
it put it in the Library of Congress
maybe you got to go there to watch it
but who wouldn't you know there you
know there are some people who would do
that I would that'd be my the
only time I ever really wanted to go to
Washington I was like I'm going to go
watch battir in the library of yeah
there was some somebody in either you
know
um the house or the Senate who was like
you know we we we're we're long overdue
a revisiting of the antitrust laws for
the for the federal trades commission
and we have to invest this feels an
awful lot like insurance fraud it feels
like you know building a house than
Burning It Down for the insurance money
which you're not supposed to do um you
know and it feels like it's a it's
defrauding a business um so to back up a
little bit uh in casee you're coming to
this late um about a week ago three days
ago whatever it was the news broke that
coyote versus Acme starring John Cena
would become the third Warner Brothers
already shot film to get shelved after
previously killing Batgirl and scoob
holiday haunt last August um clearly the
filmmakers were furious at it because of
course you are um but the thing is that
a movie was fully completed and had
tested multiple times in the 9s which
like Argo tested in the 90s both
Deadpool movies tested in the 90s um you
know and according to people who've seen
the film um which stars Will Forte and
John Cena it's really good like it is
not apparently the disaster the Batgirl
was not sure I believe Batgirl was a
disaster but whatever um apparently it's
really great you know
um and so people had started to can
canel meetings at Warner Brothers you
know filmmakers who had meetings in the
books were like if you guys like if I
enter into good faith and make a movie
with you and this is just the way you
conduct yourselves as a studio why would
I make a movie with you why would I ever
do that um and so what has happened
since is because of the outrage because
of potential legal issues because James
gun co-wrote this movie
um yeah
did he really yeah he's got a co-writing
credit on it um Warner Brothers says
reverse their decision they are not
going to release it but they're going to
allow the filmmakers to take it to
Market and see if somebody else wants to
buy it and then release it which you
know not a bad decision better than the
alternative but also bizarre given that
it's Looney
Tunes like care dude this zov guy don't
seem to give a I mean they let a
Batman show go to Amazon Batman
cartoon they're letting the DC Universe
go to Netflix as opposed to just max
it's you know it's they used to be a
very filmmaker friendly Studio that's
what they were known as and I think this
this kyot versus Zach me thing put the
you know fear of God into Warner
Brothers because a bunch of creatives
were like I'm not going there anymore
you better believe now in the
age of Disney did this right with Willow
took it off dumped it you better believe
in in the age of Studios now going oh we
can write off all right it
every filmmaker every actor their
contracts going forward on anything is
going to include a you cannot do
this without a massive
buyou yeah everyone's GNA start
protecting against this at this
point but how
nice to see like creative people make
that point and then the studio be like
all right fair enough we hear you try to
go try to sell it someplace if you can
sell it go for it there was a tweet from
uh from Peter atencio who directed uh
the Keanu movie uh with Kean Peele in it
and had directed like 70% of the keyan
peel sketches who uh would retweeted him
self from 2020 saying hey you should
become friends with like your assistant
editor treat them incredibly well and
always make sure that like once a week
they save to a hard drive that you have
access to a a sort
of whatever it is Watermark free version
of your movie because at some point
you're going to want to have that and if
this is what is going to happen in this
business where suddenly the thing that
youve made and labored for forever is is
now just vanished from the plane of
existence you should have a copy of it
for
yourself um or just be the
editor just be the
Ed 430 movie sitting right over there
nobody could even if I somebody was
taking it away from me I'm like good
luck I got the only C well JC's got I I
do as well yeah K Nolan was uh was doing
press I guess part of the the Oscar
season runup for for oppenheim and he
was talking about um all of the work
he's been doing on the DVD Blu-ray
release of Oppenheimer and he was like
oh I'm very committed to physical media
I'm I'm like all the bonus features
we're we're killing it because
you should be able to own this movie if
you want it and not have it exist at the
whim of some streaming
service like yeah true what's up one of
my friends who is um more into I used to
be called film Twitter now it's called
film X or X whatever they calling
Twitter now was saying that there was a
big movement behind the uh coyote vers
Acme movie to try to uh barbin Heimer it
meaning whoever picks it up when they
release it in the theater to just swarm
the theater to make zaslav look like the
biggest like it opened at $150
million and he sold it for a song which
I honestly could probably that would
probably get me out on like a Friday
morning to see the
movie um he's
same just like I'd see it anyway because
I love Looney
Tunes well what it's going to be like 90
minutes maybe right like it's it's going
to be quick it's going to be
funny it's e easily
digestible um and you can just you know
stick it to corporate at the same
time and also like we used to make
things physical
media why we can't let it go yeah yeah
did we talk I guess was it was it last
week the week before we talked I don't
think we' covered that Best Buy was
going to stop stalking
Blu-rays that like
and they have been like maybe one of the
last physical places you can go and buy
a Blu-Ray disc maybe Target still hasn't
maybe Walmart but I'm not sure but Best
Buy had been like committed to it until
they
weren't hold
on those were these are the clerk's 3
pops those are damaged
um but then
is some physical ass media man they they
put out this Clerk's
Saga box set I'm gonna do an unboxing
for you right
now hold
on am I gonna unbox it no because it's
sealed shelf anyway it's got movies in
it's got fake Quick Stop you put
stickers on it and then there's a box in
the back that's got like the three
movies in there um it was kind of pricey
I had to buy these nobody sent them to
me and I bought two and they were
over a hundred bucks but if you like
clerks kind of cool I saw somebody
online was unhappy with it and they were
like you know 130 bucks or
whatever the it was and it's not 4K
you know you've got my money for the
last time I you didn't I didn't get your
money I don't know who did that
I think it was an Amazon exclusive or
something but Lions Gate
put that together um and it's kind of it
is lovely I saw a lot of praise for it
as well but I saw one dude got mad
because he said it wasn't good enough
for them but I physical Media
Kids re-embrace it re-embrace it then
they can't take it away from
you um moving on yes it seems as if Tao
white TTI director of uh Thor Ragnarok
and Thor Lan
Thunder um has said that if there is
going to be a fifth installment of Thor
he would not be
involved not because he wouldn't want to
be not because he doesn't love Chris
Hemsworth and didn't have a good time in
Marvel but he just said that he's got
enough other projects in the pipeline
that he's committed to including um he's
doing a star war um he's doing an
adaptation of the kazuo isuru novel
claraa and the Sun and he's doing an
adaptation of the graphic novel The
incal or inkle I'm going to say it's in
call because that sounds cooler and and
Tig says so that's six or seven years
gone i' imagine that another Thor would
be happening a lot sooner than that and
so he just it's not in the cards for
him well he made what two he made two
out of the
four he's got half the
Thors
um yeah I mean I don't know done it oh
yeah and I'm sure you know took a lot of
heat on that last one people were
unhappy Life's too short I'm sure he's
made a Thor that people loved
and Thor that people didn't love now I'm
just gonna go make other shows like my
pirate show he makes that pirate show
does he he does I love that pirate show
and he's got like a soccer movie coming
out or something next goal
wins which looks fun married to Rita Oro
and they just bought a new I
think everything's going quite well yes
he's got what we do in the shadows in
season seven ordered for like four more
seasons or whatever gu his own industry
he don't need he don't need Thor again
but you know what Ragnarok is an amazing
movie so I'm came to play I
enjoyed that movie indeede um that boy
Tim Miller remember the guy who made the
first uh the first Deadpool movie this
kid Tim
Miller he's the next big thing
man he his boy
Genius um he is he is getting in
business with Warner Brothers um the
studio has picked up the rights to alien
Legion that old Marvel comic tale uh
that was created by Carl Potts that ran
uh God how long doesn't say exactly how
long it ran but I was introduced as part
of Epic comics in
1983 the French Foreign Legion in space
was focused on an Intergalactic
peacekeeping force that took in all
manner of species without asking too
many questions about their past
intentions um I used to love this book
this book was super dope it was
you know Starship Troopers and
rag tag band of Knuckleheads who are
tasked with going into hot zones and
cooling them off um with a grim Rod who
I think was the the uh the the breakout
character was like space Wolverine green
skin deep hostility towards Authority
Grim Rod is my porn
name yeah it is on your new o is that
the name of your OE fans yes Grim Rod
Grim Rod Grim Rod work those
nips telling you there's money to be
made there we just have to throw away
our dignity it's all that's all that's
it that's all that's that um let's see
what else we got there's a Legend of
Zelda movie that they announced but you
don't care about video games so much um
who's in it nobody yet is being produced
by avod um and directed by Wes ball who
did The Maze Runner Trilogy and who has
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes on
deck for next year oh that's his he
directed that
yeah um but you know Legend of
Zelda is a massive franchise for
Nintendo it's been 10 12 23 different
versions of that game and so yeah makes
all the sense in the world that somebody
would where where uh Super Mario
did what it did makes a billion dollars
um folks I saw some folks in chat asking
like hey man where do I get those clerks
3 pucks including the very first Dante
hick pop and
whatnot um you can get them all over the
internets kids but we sell them signed
at
job.com anyway back to the show back to
the show uh that's pretty much all the
news it's fit to print my friend let's
talk man oh bman what's up I was just
going to bring that up I saw a trailer
that got me very excited this weekend
which one Rebel Moon uh I saw Rebel Moon
I was like this is fine but I also saw
Ghostbusters did you guys see the
Ghostbusters trailer wonderful trailer
and you know what's so weird about is
it's just
like it's not they're not making it an
event it's not like your childhood's in
the balance like it's just a movie Just
a sequel ass movie
like I was so delighted all of a sudden
their trailer dropped and it's not like
the
era defining film of
2024 they're just like no it's
Ghostbusters in the snow in New York
City doesn't that sound fun I'm like
yes it sounds fun that's all it
needs to be it's a good time and we get
to see like Winston and Ray and
Venkman again like
like the only thing that I kept thinking
watching that trailer was like am I the
only one surprised that Paul rut is
still in these movies like why is he
here he was in that last one right after
life this seemed I mean it's sequel to
afterlife and whatnot um it's like I
want I kind of want to just be with the
kids I don't I I don't I didn't need
Paul Rudd to be there again I didn't
need Carrie to be there again just
like hey man don't there ain't no such
thing as Paul Rudd fatigue did you guys
put him in everything I saw a meme today
I think that is uh Wilford Brimley from
cocoon and Paul Rudd side by side and
Paul Rudd is older today than Brimley
was in cocoon right that's wild what and
yet he looks eternally youthful
and yeah Bradley pooper in chat
said Jason ason wman is a great director
I don't think Jason wman directed the
new Ghostbusters did he I don't know I
think he's producer but I don't think he
directed JC can you fact that real quick
yeah yeah I think like once every like
five years there's a new Wilford Brimley
meme because there was the Tom Cruz one
it's like Tom Cruz is as old as Wilford
Brimley was in cocoon now it's Paul Rudd
is as old was has that you've passed the
Wilford Brimley birthday yeah I think
which is like 51 or something like that
which is the was when he was in cocoon
Justin Sumi asked in chat Jason Lee and
Ethan SLE do any My Name is Earl
material on the cruise that's right kids
Jason Lee and Ethan tolea two couple M
rats gonna be Stone away on the boat
with me and Mark man Jan and Sal Bob's
Cru skew coming your way in February
2024 we're at like 70 78% sold
kids what's up there
uh Gil Keenan is the director of Frozen
Empire which by the way is such an
awesome name for the movie like it's
like Empire State but then like the
ghost that comes back as is fro oh it's
so clever the director Gil Keenan he did
uh monsterous City of Ember the 2015
Poltergeist uh and he was a writer on
Ghostbusters
afterlife hm
fun and the internet is just
going crazy over there red parkas oh
yeah like that's what veckman wore in
in the movie remember like and I
guess they were also a look from the
cartoon as
well it's uh I saw something that it was
like they tried to make this movie like
a like a big episode of the cartoon
which is kind of
cool okay I'm I'm I'm with it don't it
don't have to be like like you
know the event of the just make a
movie man just a sequel like we
used to remember in the 80s and the 90s
they just made sequels and we went and
well and it's it's coming out in
March so it wasn't like here's the
preview for the trailer that's coming
out in 6 months for the movie that's
coming out in 36 months it was just like
here's here's a teaser trailer for the
movie that will be out in 3
months yeah yeah I mean and this this I
feel is like the the front end of all of
this that was stalled because of
the actor strike now being slotted for
release and now they're like hey it's
all coming here it all is they're going
to clean up in March and I say this as a
as a movie exhibitor Mark I don't know
if you know this or not but I own a
movie theater
indeed SM Castle Cinema so I don't just
speak as a movie Watcher I speak as a
movie exhibitor and looking ahead at the
next few months
we're we're looking forward to
marching Ghostbusters
because there's not a lot coming
there's Aquaman's
coming
um what else is there there's Aquaman
Aquaman not holding out a lot of for
that either so it's uh yeah I
Ghostbusters will be a nice a nice
March glad they're not waitting until
summertime because I know as a film
exhibitor we're going to need that
sooner rather than
later indeed um I saw a trailer for um
what else did I see the trailer for
Rebel Moon which I thought was cool
looks good I'm there for scii
and I'm gonna try and see that in
theaters I'm gonna try because I know
it's playing at the Egyptian I think um
which if you're not in Los Angeles the
Egyptian is a 100-year-old movie theater
that had been on Hollywood Boulevard
since whatever the beginning of movies
that has just been sort of restored and
refurbished and and they're now back to
hosting 70 mm screenings and 35 but it's
all on film and it's all gorgeous and so
they have a 70 MIM cut a print of Rebel
Moon that they're going to be showing
there for a couple of weeks I think and
so I definitely want to see that in
person
um and Netflix bought that theater right
yeah it's a Netflix Jammy Jam so like
the killer had been there I think might
still be there um but they're big into
like here's a movie that you haven't
seen in a while or a brand new thing and
then filmmaker interviews and q&as and
so like Fincher was there talking about
the killer um I would like to see it on
a big screen but I will probably watch
it at
home if it's a Netflix theater maybe
maybe I can get in there with
Masters of the
Universe Revolution another trail that
dropped this week also the the last what
is it avatar the Last Air bendar last
air bender trailer dropped yeah Netflix
just went nuts they had their
geek tweak so they dropped a bunch of
trailers uh Masters of the
Universe Revolution um was one of them
and this is just a teaser doesn't really
give the full breath of plot doesn't
even you know it doesn't even tell you
who Shatner
is um but yeah it's uh I posted the
trailer and ran away from the internet
as fast as
I before all the mean kids came out to
be like
Boo
Boo um this is hordak versus He-Man
versus
Skeletor it's the
Battle Royale 3 and like
that the
Triumph yes and uh that comes out uh
next year but anyway the trailer for
that is up what else was there a trailer
for Fall Guy you see the Fall Guy
trailer I did see the Fall Guy trailer I
mean look I'll watch Ryan goling do
anything I'll watch Ryan goling pull the
switch on the electric chair that I'm
sitting in I'm sure he'll do it
charmingly and
that's one good Canadian
um so that trailer looks good looks
nothing like you know it's crazy because
they used the Bon Joi song and it's like
you know for my money they got one of
the greatest theme songs of all time
the unknown stuntman song which
maybe they're you know I'm sure that
means doesn't mean as much to you know
nobody going to see this
movie of a certain unless you're of a
certain age probably knows the source
material like we did yes but I'm also
100% sure that there's like a daff punk
remix of the unknown stunt man that's
going to open up that movie because of
course there
is or close it or both F yeah um and
just how like remember uh lee major sang
the theme
song the gauze should sing the theme
song Grammy nominee R he is right for
it I'm just kid
yeah uh
yeah I'm I'm I'm ready for that what
else was there trailers
for um trying to think what else I
saw in front of uh the
Marvels there's a boys in the boat did
did you see that trailer no the George
Clooney um rowing Olympic movie that he
directed about like these these like New
York kids who had been living in the
slums who en en rolled in a in a in a
crew Club in in college because it would
give them room and board and then they
made it all the way to the 1938 Olympics
to swim against
Hitler this a true story true story
which they give away most of in trailer
I like George Clooney as director I
think he's
talented it doesn't look bad it just
looks like if you see that trailer then
you've seen the movie yeah
right um uh
somebody said in chat Scott Pilgrim
versus the world anime I haven't
seen is that up yet it drops next Friday
or this Friday this Friday it
drops There's A Garfield trailer which I
haven't
seen somehow they want us to believe
that uh Sam Jackson is Chris Pratt's
father why Garfield's dad's voice is
saying Sam Jackson
yep I mean okay plot of the trailer is
like Garfield finds his father it's a
little bit like Garfield the poor orphan
cat who John takes in is it real yeah
and then at some point he sees his dad
who's a big hulking Bruiser of a cat
voiced by Sam
Jackson wow like
if somebody was like what do you think
the Garfield
m is gonna be about I don't think I ever
would have picked that I was gonna be oh
you know he hates Mondays he eats
lasagna like like oh no it's about
trauma of losing a
parent why don't he love me Uncle
Phil um wow now I now I want to see the
trailer more than ever um I'm shocked
that Chris Pratt's not also voicing
Garfield's dad he does every other role
on the in the anime made a world at this
point this is what I do now yeah really
he is the voice think about it Chris
proud is going to be the voice of an
entire generation's childhood yeah he's
there Mel
blank man of a thousand
voices more like like man of one voice a
thousand times yeah man of a thousand
jobs um I still have not seen Super
Mario Brothers but uh my kid recently
was like you have to watch it she's like
it's beautiful I was like come on and
she was like it's really really good
have you seen it no yeah mean I I was
not a big like I wasn't raised on
Nintendo so but I I feel like I should
now get around to seeing it B you know
oh B man's got he's got something to say
so I was raised on Nintendo and I love
all the Mario games and uh I watched it
and I was like h I watched it with with
Jen and she's like I loved that movie it
was so great she never had TV or
Nintendo or anything so like maybe you
don't need it she just thought it was so
wonderful so um yeah kid she didn't grow
up playing Mario so and but she loved
the flick so I maybe I maybe I'll do it
I mean it's just sitting there on where
is it peacock now is it I can watch it
for free kind of yeah let me ask you a
question fire away how often do you turn
on any other streaming service that's
not Netflix just to see what's there all
the time
really I look I spend an inordinate
amount of time surfing
tiles
and it's like as a as a you know
especially all last week I'm
just h
convalescing with with the wife and uh
for those who tuned in late my wife
shattered her hip so she's out of
commission for a while so I've been
playing nurse maid and stuff so we've
had a a long a lot of time to Surf every
streaming surver so I got
Netflix I
got Max I got Amazon Prime I got
paramont plus I got you know I pay for
premium you tube and
um I got a bunch so I surf the tiles
quite often really yes and it makes me
feel as a
Creator it makes me feel like when I use
a plastic
bottle and I'm like oh like I've
just added to the problem like before I
went to make the 430 movie I had this
real existential crisis where I
was surfing through all the tiles first
on Amazon then on
uh Max and I was like what are you doing
you're just G to make one more
tile like all these tiles and
all these movies that like no one's ever
gonna get around to watching them all
and you now you're just gonna add
another one on the pile what do
you what do you doing stop it um and
then I had to shake that off be like
this is what you do for a living like
and it's your like of course you
but yeah it i i surf the tiles a lot why
you don't uh I was thinking about it the
other day like I'll I'll turn on Netflix
and just kind of see what's there but I
can't remember the last time I went to
like Paramount plus it's like what's on
offer from Paramount plus I had to to
watch that Nathan Fielder and Emma Stone
show the the curse because it was on
Showtime oh you know what I watched on
my Showtime app but when I got to the
Showtime app they were like hey fool
we're shutting this down and you go to
paramont plus from now on but we'll let
you watch it one more time time here so
I did watch it on my Showtime man yeah
like I I I'll go to them specifically
for it like if I'm going to watch a Star
Trek I got to go to Paramount plus it
used to be Pokerface was the reason I
went to Peacock and then might have
wandered around a little bit but then
vanished pretty quickly like I'm not
poking around Apple TV to see what's
there I'm not I think it's like Netflix
Criterion ironically I'll I'll just kind
of see what's new like ooh ooh ooh this
is here ooh this is cool bound is here I
haven't seen Bound in Forever it's
always like oh I haven't seen this in
Forever um and it's a great print and
it's you know really well presented like
I'll I'll dig into that but it's I
was just I was idly
wondering you know at what point
especially as they're all starting to
charge More For Less you know like I got
this email from from Max was like hey
Max subscriber you know how this is what
you currently pay for for 15 bucks a
month and here's what you get now if you
want to keep this particular brand of
service it's going to cost you $3 more
if you want to keep paying the same
amount of money we're going to take
away I was like
huh okay that seems weird I mean I
understand it as a as a person in the
world who's paying attention to how
streaming services are not making that
much money so they're just going to
begin squeezing people um but it just
got me thinking about my habits as
regards to streaming tile surfing and
how much of it I don't actually
do I spend a lot of time shopping
looking for something and um I got high
marks this week for being a a good DJ
who was like kept stuff going
and kept her mind off of her hip and
like that so yeah I've I've been
digging deep and uh but you know my
secret go-to is always
YouTube because worst cas scenario you
can watch some SNL skits that's very
true um but I also like the midest touch
the guys that you know that that's you
know I'm not very political person but I
do listen to their show all the time um
just to hear what's going on in the
government and
and every time I listen to
something about it I'm just like I know
that's like supposed to be the domain of
grown-ups you know like government and
and people that wear suits and ties and
like
that
um but I don't know I
just I just prefer our makeb believe
World
Mark I mean it makes its own kind of
sense this make believe
world yeah I just want to tell some
stories until I drop dead and
but I feel every once in a while I'm
like I should get educated on what's
going on in the world pull my head out
of my ass and see what's going on
politically in the
landscape and so I watch that show B
what's up you know what I did the other
day I was I found myself uh at vidiots
which is it used to be a video store on
the west side right yeah so I I was
there for a thing that I don't know if I
can talk about but I was there for a
thing uh a work related event and I
walked into their video store and they
have like
60,000 movies or something ridiculous
there and I found myself browsing their
movie collection and they have an
awesome theater and like I don't I've
never been into like like going to the
new Bev or the C family or any of the
like La movie scenes they always kind of
seem like clicky and pretentious and
full of but I walked into that
place and it was so laidback and cool um
and like just looking at physical movies
like they had
the collector's edition of Cloak and
Dagger that like video game movie with
the kid from
ET yeah and I found myself like holding
that and being like I really want
to rent this even though I know I have
it at home um it just seems so chill and
the movie theater's got like a bar in
the lobby it's this gorgeous movie
theater anyway the
movie it's big it's
probably it's about the size of the big
house at SM Castle 250 seats yeah 275
maybe tell me about I think Liz Destro
the producer on the on last my last few
flicks including the 430 movie was
telling me about it and I was like this
sounds like a place that maybe we could
do a local SM Castle Cinemas program at
so like all the I do at SM Castle
Cinemas I got a lot of people out here
going like do it here show Jersey the
extended cut out here uh
and yeah that could be the place like
rather than buying well I mean as if
that's an option I don't really have
that option but as opposed to like back
home I bought a movie theater with my
friends I can't do that out here I'll
tell you the the other thing we could do
there if we some m is that scum and vill
has a catering license so we could do a
scum villain popup with a SM Castle
Cinemas movie screening at vidiots so
vidiots doesn't sell booze so you could
bring booze in to sell they sell I think
they have a beer and wine license but
they don't have like an alcohol license
so like we could bring stuff in and uh
and make an you know make a weekend of
it I like it it was so Co it was so cool
a lot of people I know and trust
including you both speak very highly of
the space yeah I went to go see aliens
there um a couple months ago and uh
because they are a straightup legit rep
house they can get show that though
that's a fox film and Disney owns it
because and I remember this from from
trying to do at the at the Alamo
Draft House was that Disney's okay with
rep houses that are 100% rep houses that
don't show current movies they just
don't with people who also show uh
first run and reparatory stuff and so
that's their loophole H um like the new
Bev granted it's Quenton so he can do
whatever he wants but the new Bev can
also program Fox and like classic Disney
animated stuff like they'll do
you know Robin Hood and Sword and the
stone and Black Cauldron and
all day long
um should we do some Q&A we could yeah
we should but I somebody in chat
said you know
what don't chase it
down yeah someone wasn't happy that
you know I'm I'm not more tuned
into
to the world
or
or let me see how do
I you know before I was talking about
like I you know I I'm not
very like politically tuned in and blah
blah
blah somebody's just
like I mean this is not what they said
but I'm that's the problem I'm part of
the I'm the problem with the World Mark
is that I'm
not thinking about that stuff kids I'm
gonna say it one more
time my place in this world as I see it
is to be the distraction for that I'm
just clown an idiot over here
who does hopefully funny things
to distract you from your own eventual
demise and the horrors in the world so
I'm not a person to be taken seriously
never have been and never said that I
wanted to be um so yeah if you're if you
come here and you're like hey man you
should get political like you
come to the wrong place there's so many
wonderful places for that of people who
actually know what they're talking
about um you know I'm
53 and all I want to talk about is make
pretend stuff like that's my function in
the world is
to make try to make people laugh try to
give people comfort you know not
everyone goes for it and but it's
clearly enough people have gone for it
that I've been doing it for like 30
years and stuff but you don't need me
weighing in on politics and you know
what my politics are look at my movies
and but you don't need me getting
specific and so no me and Mark are not
part of the problem I
don't I do spend you know do you guys
have your
iPhone like what dissension from within
our ranks F man no do you guys get the
um the screen time alerts like
congratulations your screen time was
down 20% last week for a total of 6
hours a day you're like I spend a
quarter of my life on this phone
but a lot of people it's like Instagram
or Twitter or Facebook mine is always
Yahoo news and so I read a lot of news
and every day I'm going stop right there
y Yahoo news I go to yahooo news yeah
Yahoo still exists I mean because
because you've found a time machine like
was was was ask geves busy it's Yahoo
They while you're at Yahoo you might
want to Yahoo Google and look into
that Bing won't take my calls anymore so
I at yah the Curiosity and I'm not
on it if you like yaho but I
mean I haven't heard anyone it
it's a it is an aggregate right so you
never are actually reading Yahoo news
stories it pulls from different things
and there's of course something about
that's your search engine of choice JC
not my search engine just for news so
I'll go to Yahoo and I'll scroll the
front Page's Newsfeed my Google front
page just says Google with like a funny
little thing depending on what's going
on my my Google where's your algorithm
at Yahoo
uh it I mean my Google page it just says
Google I don't have any of the other
crap on there well neither does mine but
then you go to the menu for Google
News know that got to do this but I get
my from Google where do you get
your news
Mark uh there's a guy on the corner who
seems to know a lot about a
lot um it used to be uh the site
formerly known as Twitter um because I
would there there was a handful of
journalists that I liked to follow who
would kind of you know kind of Dove tail
me through what whatever was happening
in the world um now it is it is more
often than not Google it is more often
than not Apple like apple who is now
doing some of that aggregation work and
just like appears as like a top story on
my thing or whatever and it's pulling
from New York Times from The Wall Street
Journal and Washington Post and Yahoo
um but yeah like I'm not I'm I am rarely
like a I'm going to dive deep on the
news this day I'm more like a did
something happen I need to hear about
okay let me investigate we uh
interrupted ban because we were
so but he's got a point to his story
it's not just I I use Yahoo it's
something else go well so I wake up
every morning and I I go to Yahoo like
if I'm on my phone for 6 hours a day
like 4 hours of it is reading news uh um
just because I want to see is today the
day of the world is going to end in some
horrible way and am I going to be
prepared for it a and essentially that's
it you could spend 4 hours a day reading
the news and it's all bad and it's not
you're not learning anything it's just
like Donald Trump had another court case
today and people said stuff and there's
outrage over whatever somebody said on
both sides and you're you're like oh
okay that again you know oh more bombs
were dropped in a bunch of different
places that
again it's all bad and you're not any
smarter or more well-informed
you just know that there's all sorts of
bad stuff happening which pretty much
you know anyway it's not like you're
making like it's not going to change who
you're voting for you know what I mean
like it's not like you're on the edge of
being like should
I you you know I think I'm going to vote
for uh Robert Kennedy this this time out
like it's not going to change anything
so like don't it
doesn't like you're not the problem like
I'm the problem I'm feeding into the
algorithm that's selling the rage clicks
like that's the problem
yeah I am I'm a Google news guy and um
it took me a while to realize it's like
oh it's going to give you the kind of
news that you click
on like when I when I figured out oh
it's learning
me um you know I then I realized I'm I'm
only seeing news that you know you'd
be be if you saw my Google news feed you
would not be
shocked you know I think you'd be like
there's an awful lot of entertainment
news in here but I do I do stay bre like
I get up in the morning and I like my
father used to read the newspaper I hit
Google news in the morning and sit there
and read like everything that's
happening that day the front page and
stuff um but doesn't mean I'm educated
about it just means that I'm AB breasted
um it's t i mean
it's I am a a oh let's fix it or here's
the solution kind of person and that's
easy when you're like making
movies or you're in the Kevin Smith
business business and but like you
can't do that in the real world where
you're like oh here's an easy solution
to what's going on someplace else like I
don't have any answers that's why I feel
it's best to just be the guy that's like
hey man let me tell you about the time
that
Victor Garber came on our
show he's coming on our
show
no I I'll say never I also once a week
getting ready for trivia so tomorrow
morning instead of going to Yahoo news
like it's
1995 I'll go I go to like den of geek
and collider and I read all the geek and
entertainment news for the week to write
trivia from yeah my uh I mean in in all
fairness and and cander I do get my news
more more from the not from
television like I I get up at like 7:00
a.m. every day and the first thing that
goes on is like like the Today Show and
so I will get their first 20 minutes
which is you know I'm not going to say
comprehensive but like what's happening
in the world the first half an hour of
the Today's Show is when you're going to
get that my wife likes to watch the five
o'clock news so sometimes I'll just sit
with her as she pours through that stuff
which some of it is important some of it
is just like here's what's happening in
an arbor that was weird because a moose
ran through a guy's house
today okay um you know and then like
MSNBC is on some times John Oliver is a
great source of my news watch I watch
that every week as well in the way that
The Daily Show with John Stewart used to
be you know not as John Stewart intended
because he would always say we're not a
new show I'm a comedian trying my best
but I I would still sort of get at least
perspective from that stuff um but yeah
like I I similarly to to JC and to you I
can't fix it I generally know what's
happening is you know I know how I feel
about it sometimes occasionally I
will portray or reveal how I feel about
it on the internet for people to see
more often than not I
don't um because sometimes I don't have
anything to add to the
conversation I mean like I'm just not
smart enough to
like offer an opinion on how to solve
The World's
problems and nor am I in a position to
have that opinion heard or do anything
about it you
know yeah yeah I mean I am smart enough
I just don't want the
pain that too there's so little to be
gained it's just not my like not what
I'm here to do I'm not I
wouldn't be good at it I'd ruin things
Doug unfunny in chat said Supreme Court
is corrupt they overturn roie weight it
matters to know who to remove from
office of of course like I'm did I paint
myself as completely ignorant I'm just
saying I I I believe it all started with
me talking about how much news I consume
and I try to consume more to stay a
breast he he but
um you know it doesn't make me feel like
an adult as you
just um it doesn't to get back to the
nipple work that me and Mark were
promising
earlier um it just doesn't like like I'm
not like I don't consume the news and
then turn around and regurgitate it to
the World going like and I'm
mad like I you got plenty of people to
do that I'll be over here going like if
you come to be I'm mad I'm gonna try to
make it laugh
like take the you know edge off and
like I don't know that's I'm not the guy
you come to because I'm like yeah I'm
mad too like
that's why I can't do you know we open
the show talking about like let's do
outrage that's clicks but I'm
not was that line in Barton
Frink um John Goodman's like they say
I'm a mad man but I'm not mad at
anybody most people I just feel sorry
for um that's from a movie that's not
out um all right let's go to the q& a
all right let's do it
um can we talk before we dive into that
Rick and Morty season s yeah it's
happening right now and some people of
course have opinions about the changing
of the voices and whatnot step that
aside the most recent episode that just
went up like brings to a close a
storyline they've been with for
a few
seasons
um it's it's always a funny show but
like Ricky Morty remains some of my
favorite sci-fi at the moment like
they're they're always telling a
story that at the end of which I'm like
man I couldn't do that like
that's that's smart um and uh the most
recent episode like was was pretty
pretty wonderful I you know I know some
people are
like you know oh it ain't the same
anymore but I thought this episode stood
shoulder toh shoulder with some of the
other mythology episodes they've done I
had a really good time watching it nice
I uh I have never seen an episode of
Rick and Morty and uh I I have this to
offer though that um the new voice
actors came into the bar a few weeks ago
on a Tuesday night to
celebrate the show coming out and them
being on the show and they were awesome
so I am all for it because they came to
my bar to celebrate their
non uh Star Wars Sci-Fi show and uh and
we're fantastic uh guests of the bar and
had a really good time so I I have that
to add to anybody who doesn't like those
guys I like them because they uh help
pay for my daughter's birthday party
this weekend so they they sound like it
to me I you know I've been watching Rick
and Morty for years and there are
moments where it's like oh that's not
the way it would normally be inflected
by Justin but I thought the the new
voices totally
work um you know at least for Rick and
Morty Mr Poopy butthole who was in like
the first episode didn't quite sound
like
him um but in any event yeah it
was I thought it was I enjoyed the
out of the most recent
episode um okay all right let
us says feels like a stolen show what
Rick and
Morty aren't the same still working on
it with the exception of
one I I I believe so is Dan Harmon still
working on
it I think so yeah yeah because he's
doing interviews about him
instead um you know you could certainly
say it feels like somebody's missing but
I I don't know that it
feels um stolen
any
who
anyo uh all right crypto Scotty wanted
to
know uh if you
could blow up large one IP to fight
Godzilla who or what would you pick so
you could blow up anything to fight
Godzilla like make it
big have you anyone seen the Godzilla
minus zero Trail yes it looks
dope looks Fant fantastic um okay I can
blow up anything to fight
Godzilla I'll
go Michelangelo from the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles I just think that'd be
very fun well he's a ninja and he could
surf big waves in the ocean he's
amphibious so I feel like it'd be a
pretty good match Godzilla can shoot
fire blast things and Michelangelo has
numo I think it' just be silly it'd be
fun probably have to be a cartoon I
don't know if you could get away with a
live
action um plus they cross over Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles with everything
else now I think it uh I think it would
work
um I saw a cat like Chase down like one
of them lizards in in the garden I don't
know if it's a gecko but one of those
fast things M and the cat was
super fast it didn't matter that thing
was fast cat got
it so I'm gonna say any ass house cat
blown up as big if not bigger than
Godzilla is gonna take Godzilla out cats
are horribly vicious and if not
for the fact that they're so tiny I
think they'd kill us all um so I think
you blow up any ass cat I'm not even
talking about Chris Pratt's
Garfield Garfield's dead you take any
ass house cat man especially a board one
blow that up and be like go take
care of all Atomic breath oh ripped the
tail off pulled a head
off slap that body around and
and cute cute like to see a giant
cat problem is once he's done
with Godzilla you're all
next I was I was tempted to go uh a
robot um only because of the classic
sort of Kaiju versus giant mot robot
thing but that feels Dum and easy like
because we've all seen Pacific Rim we
know what that
is um and then I got kind of fascinated
with the idea of uh of Clubber Lang
versus
Godzilla Mr T against a Godzilla seems
like the way to go especially
when he impunes Godzilla's coxm
ship right in front of him when he's
like you want real man come on I'll show
you the real
man and then and then I started thinking
about the KGAN from
Highlander um basic basically it's the
it's the imputing of the mhip
basically he's like oh she was your
woman I took his head and I raped his
woman before his body was even cold oh I
see this was in a Godzilla movie what
movie this is an Highlander oh yeah the
KGAN versus yeah he's pretty horrible
the K he's pretty horrible but then I
was like you know what would be just
more fun and more adorable it is like
stap puff marshmallow man who's already
huge versus Godzilla only because then
you get to toast the bu Marshall man
with atomic fire nice nice we all win
there delicious for everybody bring your
graham crackers and it's it's a
party um good question he's just a
sailor he's in town wants to have a good
time
um related to Clubber Lang did you guys
watch the sly documentary on loved it
holy thank you for bringing it up
loved it and like I'm not like I I like
Sylvester Stallone I've liked Sylvester
Stallone movies across my lifetime and
whatnot but I'm not like you know
I don't have a poster of
Sylvester Stallone hanging up although
I've always enjoyed and and liked his
journey right he's a guy came from
nowhere believed in himself
wrote Rocky they tried to buy it
away from him and cast other people he's
like no no I'm gonna be in this and
and you know he's this guy created three
franchises for himself but he's a
screenwriter and he's a director as well
as actor icon and stuff like
that so I've always had respect for him
and whatnot but like I would I was never
like you know sly's my guy I
thought the documentary was wonderful
absolutely wonderful
like is is worth
watching yeah
I it definitely portrays him and I know
he was involved in it he's like I am a
writer first above all
yeah and like Quenton long writer like
writes out long him and somebody else
types it and stuff yeah like I I dug it
but and it's it's I suppose it's natural
to want to compare it to the Arnold
Schwarzenegger documentary series that
they did which I didn't watch and that
was I hav't watched that yet it's four
episodes this was this was one and done
you're out in two hours one and done and
I and I think I like the Arnold one
better only because it goes a bit deeper
like the sly one is it's it's very much
about his art it's very much about him
as an actor and a writer and a producer
um but it does not go very deeply at all
into his family stuff like it talks
about his dad but like I don't know who
his wife is I don't know who any of
those children are he never talks about
the death of his son which I'm
like never well he talks but not about
it specifically like
he talks about his son but then they
just flashed the like 1978 to 200
whatever for sage toone I was like oh
that's that's moving but
like you know like I I like I dug it
especially in the front end of it
because it's it's revealing the creation
of an artist which is super interesting
to me um but towards the talent of it it
doesn't go that deep into like all right
well who is he now like what is he about
what's what's beneath that surface you
could literally do an entire documentary
on just Rocky
yeah then you could do a whole
documentary on just
Rambo then you could do a whole
documentary on just the Expendables and
then they had to do everything else and
cram this dude's entire life and all the
other movies and his ups and downs yeah
like there's a great story in the Arnold
documentary where he talks about the
Rivalry that they had in the 80s and 90s
and the like he tells the story of how
he gets Stallone to Star and stoer my
mom will shoot he does that in in the
Stallone duck in Sly does he because
because I remember he goes I mean maybe
it's because Arnold came first but he
talks about how he kept telling Sly that
he was going to star in it and so sly's
like well it I want to do it I want
to do it I want to do it and then Arnold
drops out it's like I was never going to
Star this movie it's awful then
Stallone is stuck being in stoper my M
shoot
um somebody asked in chat uh who was it
uh Davey sock rocker said does it talk
about Oscar it does it does they spend
like a shocking amount of time on
Oscar and he kind of defends like far or
whatever they called it yeah it is it is
a good it's a good time for Netflix and
kind of documentaries about Fame you
know between the Arnold do between slime
between the Beckham I started watching
the Beckham one out of out of Sly I was
like Arnold or Beckham and I actually
went with Beckham cuz I know nothing
about them yeah like it's it's kind of
amazing the Arnold stuff like it's
because Arnold has had so many chapters
in his life um is what makes that kind
of at least to me a little bit deeper
than the sly things because sly's had
two chapters I've had I'm a nobody actor
just banging around New York and
I'm Sylvester Stallone um where AR was
like bodybuilder movie star politician
womanizer a you know a Lion in Winter
what am I doing with like it's it's got
more places to go um but yeah and
apparently there's a Robbie Williams
documentary that's pretty good and
that's another dude who like came out of
nowhere and blew up in the world stage
and then kind of vanished shortly
thereafter there's an Albert Brooks
documentary on HB I want to watch I I
love Albert Brooks that docent great
there's a Wham documentary on on Netflix
that's fascinating fantastic I watched
it a couple months ago or whenever it
first dropped love that documentary
shocked how many of those songs I could
sing I was like oh my God I guess I was
a Wham
fan like everybody kind of was in the
80s um but that talk is great uh did you
guys know that Albert Brooks's this was
a trivia question a couple weeks ago
Albert Brooks's real name was Albert
Einstein he changed to Brooks yeah
Reon um
okay question number two all right
question two first one only uh neba says
which fictional character do Mark and
Kevin think they look
like I think I look like Silent
[Laughter]
Bob thank you um I don't don't think I
look like him but I've uh there have
been a lot of people whenever I'm like I
got a jacket on and my hair is done up
and I'm not wearing a baseball cap
they're like oh my God you look like
Robert Downey
Jr um which I don't I think it's just
because the
beard shape of it and my delivery or
something like that I told the story on
that the mental health video that when I
was at
CR um like I was sitting around
and there's a new guy came in from
Detroit and we were and I'd
been there for a couple weeks so I was
able to be like hey this is this and
this is that blah blah blah this is when
you you know this is how you get
a vegan burger for lunch if you want it
and um after we were talking for 20
minutes and he was like um man did
anyone ever tell you you look like that
famous guy and I thought for sure he was
going to be like you know I thought he
was talking about the character I play
in movies and so I was getting
ready to be like well yes I have also
been Silent Bob before I could
say anything he goes Robert Downey Jr
and that just made every that
made you know going to the mental
hospital worth it for
me somebody be like you remind me of
Robert dowy Jr I was like I love Iron
Man thank you um all right so
uh but hands down son buub what about
you uh I I I never get confused or even
told I look like a famous person um when
I I was just starting to work for
Entertainment Weekly I just got first
like on staff full-time and I had a
retreat to the uh moh hunk mountainous
in Upstate New York um and so there was
whatever the 80 some OD people who
worked on the staff we all went away for
a weekend because this when publishing
made money and you could afford to do
that and the first night they had a uh
it was exceeding as if it was a wedding
and so you figured out where you were
sitting but went to the table that had
all the names on it but instead of the
names there was the the celebrity
doppelganger that you had and mine was
Tracy
Morgan and I was
like Blair Underwood is right there you
guys Denzel is like there's I'm
the black dude on staff I could have
been William December Williams
but no I'm Tracy MO Morgan all right
fine whatever you're more you're more
Idris album man you're
total um on the picket line I know on
the picket line I got I got legit
mistaken more than once for the guy who
wrote and directed One Night in Miami
who
co-directed um into the spiderverse and
soul uh writer named writer director
named Kemp
Powers um literally I had like four
people be like are you Kemp powers
no I just wish I had his career I see
that I did a lot of award season stuff
with Kemp a couple years ago when he was
like promoting soul and one night in
Miami constantly I see that yeah like I
when I look at him like you know I see
how you got there um thank you I am not
him I cannot I I literally walked on the
line for 20 minutes with a dude who was
asking me questions about one night in
Miami expecting me to answer them and I
didn't quite I he all he would say was
like I really loved your movie and I was
like oh thank you very much we just
finished it a little while ago now I'm
working on some comic books like you do
comic books that's odd and it was only
at the end of this conversation did he
says hey man I just I wanted to tell you
I just loved one night in Miami I was
like oh you think I'm somebody else he's
like what comic are you working on
you're like one about Muhammad Ali and
he's like really One Night in Miami yeah
makes sense you did all the research I'm
like how did you know I did so much
research I did thank you
what about you JC who do you look like
anyone tell you the one that I get
constantly not as much with the new
haircut uh was uh Adam Scott I guess Ben
Wyatt from Parks and wreck I could
totally see that now that you
say it oh my God you're absolutely right
yes what's his name Adam Scott yeah Adam
Scott people at the bar tell me that all
the time and then the one that I get on
like the internet a lot is like uh the
ugly version of Sam
Witwer um so like I guess Star Killer
from Force
Unleashed uh which I think has more to
do that we're just like pasty white
vampires from the Chicago suburbs than
it we actually look like each other but
I think our voices and accent and
delivery is very similar because we grew
up
together Tony balona in chat says JC
looks like Ellen
degenerous I perhaps with the stupid
haircut yeah maybe the Mohawk is what
does
it um uh hazy wave says JC looks like
sha gun maybe maybe if I lost like 20
more pounds and gained about a foot yeah
there's some Adam Ant happening though
that's true Don't drink don't smoke what
do you
do um a Kabuki kid said in
quotes I must say you think she look
like EG oh
[Laughter]
egg do a barrel roll in chat thinks you
look like something about
Mary you've gota well it doesn't
like when the whole thing's up but I
have to wear
headphones um all right uh okay do our
third and final question of the evening
uh last one since we've all talked
talked about getting older
tonight uh Jeremiah Freeman wanted to
know if we were getting dementia and
could watch one movie every day for the
rest of our life like it was the first
time what movie would it be and
why tempted to say groundhog day but
that's
not um what what movie and every day it
would be a
surprise
I mean the six cents wouldn't be a bad
one because like every viewing you'd be
like no way he was dead the
whole time and like the next day you
watch it again you're like no
what you'd be the worst person in the
nursing home it's like this guy
again with
this he loves the six sense he just
don't remember
it what a gift every brand new viewing
of the six sense form
um do I want one of my
movies you'd be like that silent Bill
guy looks just like me yeah I like that
actor cut of his jib I hope he does more
things it's not bad it could be
[Laughter]
shorter um yeah let me see
I know I'm tempted to say endgame
because like it's so utterly enjoyable
but if you went in cold to
endgame as you would if you were
forgetting every time would it be the
same movie because you wouldn't know the
all the movies leading up to it yeah
feels like it needs to be a singular
thing yeah Standalone
right could you imagine if it was like
Back to the Future
too what's Happening Here what happened
and what's gonna happen next is
the worst
[Laughter]
Choice um maybe Cinema
Paradiso love that movie and I still
love the ending of that movie one of my
favorite endings to a movie of all time
very emotional and I think that would be
beautiful to ReDiscover every day as if
it was the first time I mean oh my God
to see a movie that epic that
touching over and over again for the
rest of your life and never remembering
that you've already seen it even though
I remember seeing it I still enjoy
watching that movie it's still so like
it's about the love of
movies what about you guys I mean I'm
tempted to say into the
spiderverse
um you know it's it's it doesn't require
previous knowledge of Spider-Man and it
does a very good job of of introducing
you to the whole Spider-Man
concept okay let's do this for the last
time yeah and then tell you everything
you need to know
um I think and I'm also tempted to do
like some big reveal like you
know the The Usual Suspects you know
it's like oh oh oh that's what like you
know like the six sense like oh some big
giant twist that I that I never see
coming
um but I think I'm going to choose like
The Princess Bride that's what I was
gonna say you know like it's it's a
perfect movie it's so sweet it's
funny it's it's this just confection of
a film that
that
you'll I don't know like it's just it it
feels like the warmth that you want to
be able to to live in for for a good
long while um you know in the same way
that cinma Paradiso is that kind of
thing which it's just like hey I just
want to be hugged for two hours um and
transported into a place that has no
pain and has no fear and has no whatever
it's just wonder and
Glory um Matt dotco in chat said
honestly surprised no one here has said
Star Wars meaning in chat or on the show
too easy it's like of course about it
yeah um mad 14 said Raiders of the Lost
AR or ET great choices oh
ET yeah live stream says the Matrix
great choice I almost went with Iron
Giant oh another great choice because
it's just I remember being surprised by
how much that movie affected me because
I had so little expectations for it and
was just knocked out by
[Music]
it uh JC you co-signed uh Princess Bride
yeah I mean like you could choose almost
any one of the Pixar movies also I feel
like early
Pixar Toy Story I think would be great
oh my god did you see that
inside out two
trailer yeah for the Pixar movie you
know they're doing it again
perfect that movie gon to make a lot of
money and it's it broke records for a
Disney trailer or Pixar trailer it's the
most watched Disney trailer of
all time or something
wow um yeah they introduce more emotions
anxiety anxiety who was voiced by I
think Maya
Hawk um yeah I can't wait man I like
that first one oh somebody said project
Cheney rabbit Who Framed Roger Rabbit
would be a good
one
yeah um last born in chat says no one
for cocoon
no no way yeah like if you're an old
person
maybe it's the Lloyd dobler choice right
like hey everybody we're gonna watch
this movie Cocoon uh here's pretty good
uh you you all find it very relatable I
think think I think uh yeah maybe if I
was sitting there like the
concept of like you'll never get older
and you'll never die as Wilford Brimley
said to his grandson would be comforting
so cocoon is
a strong choice at first I was giving it
the Harry eyeball but now I'm like you
know what I'm not think I'm thinking of
me now not me when I'm an old man and
what would make me feel comforted seeing
other old people getting in the pool
with giant space eggs getting the rocks
off that might do it for
[Laughter]
me that's it
huh that's a
show a whole show kid a whole ass three
hours worth of show three hours and 15
minutes worth of
show man oh man see we're never GNA get
them
big views that the hate
shows get dude cuz we're too long we're
too long and we like
things we don't belong in this
world uh let recipe for
love too long and we like
things I just can't I can't I can't I
don't have hate in my
heart uh I love to uh chitchat about
these Dopey
things do you enjoy yourselves kids I
know I enjoyed
myself um somewhere upstairs I have a
patient who's like what the
three hours with strangers I'm up
here with a busted hip so I'm
gonna go back put on my nurse ratchet
cap candy striper most compassionate
nurse in cinem histry and uh and
take care of the patient y'all have a
good time
kids if you did it has everything to do
with the other two guys man give it up
for B man he put us into your homes onto
your
phones wherever you're watching us right
now I think we had 2,000 people at Max
or whatever the we'll take it yeah
that's that's because B man brought you
there thank you B man um and the guy
with all the intelligent
intelligence um is the intelligent
elegant Mark Bernard ladies and
gentlemen
thank you sir he's the reason you
come me you're like oh let's see what
that old Clown's up to silent Biff I
remember him from back in the
day I'm like Paul Lind and the
old Hollywood Squares people like I
don't know what he's what he did but
he's always there and that makes me feel
good he's famous just for being
famous um but once you get here you get
quality programming because Mark's smart
we try our best in these parts they nard
um there it is
kids Lots uh lots more when are we doing
this again people asking us when we're
doing this in the B when we doing it
live that is entirely up to you sir you
tell us when you can break away from uh
from your
patient yeah good point JC when are we
gonna go live again when do we go to the
bar B
um we could do there was one request
that we do uh from chat the 28th which
would be the Tuesday after
Thanksgiving if people are around then
two weeks from today I'm
down let do it to
it it'll actually probably be a shorter
show than the one today because you just
drive down we do 90 minutes you're home
and be under three hours
true yeah free to uh to help uh spell
you on on nursemate
duty that be
me I can ask her to do that so I could
just go to the
bar I gotta go to the bar going to the
bar ma get in the car go to the bar
Earth gazer is pointing out we are
getting close to the 500th episode is
that true no is it oh we're we just do
400 yeah we're at
4133 I mean technically I guess we are
getting closer to 500 just not that
close it's always there it's like three
years away we do about 26 shows a year
on average so we're about three years
away stick
around we're getting
there um there it is my
friends there it is
um a Nani Mass all night in chat has
said oh my God Kevin Smith just read my
comment I'm your youngest fan at 11
please respond quickly it took me a
while but there's my response anani Mas
anani M now go to sleep yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna make sure my patient is
sleeping go to bed n m yeah you yeah
you're 11
aart
all right folks there it is kids um did
you have a good time I know I
did thanks for hanging out with us man
hell yeah we'll do it
again uh for
Fatman Beyond kids uh that's it for fat
man beyond tune in no how do I do
this and that I was I was
confusing it with Babel going and that
how do I end
it uh I'm trying to remember I know
right because I never do it uh that's
fat man beyond for this week kids I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernard and tune in
next week for
same and that my friends is fat man
Bound for this week um I'm Kevin Smith
and I'm Mark Bernard tune in next time
we're back on track same fat Time same
fat Channel
uh smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevinsmith and then The Dore Jeff's
kiss this is the greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask keev anything
every Saga has a 10year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with Jay and S Bob get old I'm
Kevin Smith